brooks before you moved to hollywood
what was the picture you had in your
mind of what it meant to be a working
hollywood screenwriter that's a great
question um
if before i went to hollywood my thought
of being
a working screenwriter is
um
sort of non-stop five projects at a time
this one that one the other one and um
you know finishing one and and getting
on to another one i think that's
pretty much what i would
think back back then
so when you're at nyu or even before
you had this vision that it would be
non-stop work phone ringing
people wanting to have meetings maybe
yeah yeah so yeah the idea made it was
um
what's so interesting is that a lot of
people talk about oh have you made it if
you broke it in or whatever um and it's
it's kind of amorphous when you go what
does that mean to you that you made it
and people usually go screen cybers i
don't really know so that was
certainly the case for me i mean when i
started um
i was making movies with my friends in
high school and um it was so much fun
and i just was like look nothing in my
life is more fun than this how can i do
this as much as possible and then i was
like oh well i can go to study at nyu
film school and i went and so and then
at that point i just
i would have probably if i was pushed to
define making it i would have thought
yeah making something that's widely
released
and everybody knows you and your
whatever and my thought was yeah you're
sort of working constantly um
that's probably how i how i thought
about it back then
in terms of the process of the work
did you think that it would just be as
easy as sitting down and you know
having a glass of wine or whiskey or
whatever and just music in the
background and it's all pours out or did
you realize that it would be
more painstaking
uh
that's interesting um
well because the way i started um with
my friends it was
there was a social aspect of it it was
like i wanted to do this with my friends
i liked them and we had this idea to do
together and it was fun so there was a
very team oriented start to when i made
movies and then on my own i would do my
own experiments and then as i got to
film school i learned
that expressing my own voice was really
powerful and satisfying in a way so i
became
pretty good at um working on other
people's projects and supporting them uh
co-writing
and collaborating in groups and you know
leading following and everything in
between um
so the um
so the process
was sort of intoxicating engaging
fascinating and like layered and levels
and so i um
so yeah so the creativity the creative
part of it and the process oh it always
came pretty naturally and was deeply
engrossing to me so
um there were things that back then i
would consider hard or difficult or
whatever
um
about the process but
the way i approach it now
it's never hard it's always easy and
it's because
i frame it in a way that makes it easy
whereas back then i didn't know how to
do that so i was generally having fun
but very often going wow this is so hard
this is difficult i was looking at the
the what was going on in certain ways
without realizing that was undermining
the power of my process
and when did you realize that
it was much different than
your first visions of what a working
successful hollywood screenwriter is
yeah that's that's a good question so i
right out of nyu film school when i was
22 years old i made a rote directed and
produced feature um
and then we kind of ran out of money
and it took a couple years to kind of
get edited and put out there and i ended
up taking it on this really fun um
college tour because it was a college it
was a movie about my friends on the nyu
soccer team and how we were pretty good
at playing soccer but really good at
drinking after games
and that's probably a more interesting
encapsulation of what it actually was
but like there were some good aspects of
it but it was really kind of like a
graduate level student feature it was
kind of weird 22. um
but i but i took that film to um all
these different college campuses on this
college tour and i played it for uh for
for a month
in new york city at this off-broadway
space called new york city's gorilla
cinema that we created and it was a lot
of fun so um
so i was getting
a first-hand experience of how
challenging it can be to get people in
the seats you know i did this movie
people that saw it liked it for what it
was um and it was like well geez how do
i how does that work how do you get
people it's not just i made a movie and
everybody shows up and it's not exactly
like you know it didn't get into
sundance so i didn't have the you know
kevin smith experience or richard
linklater those guys um
uh so um
but it was the whole thing was fun the
the craziest promotion we did in at that
time
at one point even me or my friend that
was doing it because actually
in addition to screening my movie we
screened my friend's independent feature
too so like mine was odd nights his was
even nights we both did it together so
we were both promoting these two
independent films
together at one point we even put like a
gorilla suit on around the street we're
doing all sorts of things and um so
how uh so i got a firsthand experience
of what it's like to be the business
part of it how do you get people how
difficult is it to tell people about
your movie and get them to care about it
and who is going to care about this
movie because i wasn't thinking about
that i was just thinking about my own
voice and something that felt true to me
at the time you know for good and for
bad
how is that picture of being a working
hollywood screenwriter different now
well i think the creative part of it is
the same i'm no more or less creative
than i ever was
and my love of it is basically the same
but i'm able to look at the process in a
way that's
deeper
and more fun
and easier
and so
the quality of my
choices that are going to be more
impactful they come more often and they
come at a greater flow and when i have
the ideas that are just a little bumpy
or not quite as strong
i don't get hung up on them so it's sort
of the grace of my
efficiency has increased significantly
and the way i think about it and the way
i allow myself to have more joy more
often so my creative process is
profoundly different although like
if you asked me one single question i
had to have a creative answer to that
now or when i was 22 would be kind of
the same but my craft is profoundly
different and how that relates to
the way i see working
writers
you know and myself it's it's
my creativity will be that i'll be hired
by producers to work on some sort of
project and um
and then i show up and we're we see it
through fruition and it just
and there's sometimes overlapping
projects and there's sometimes lulls in
between and then when there's a lull in
between i'm writing my own new spec
material so i'm always writing
and there's joys of writing my own spec
material and there's joys of writing on
assignment
you know i mean the money part of the
assignment guaranteed is nice
but it's really
the deeper
joy there for me is i'm working with a
team of people and we have to find out a
way where i'm loving it and they're
loving it um i mean ultimately they get
the final say but they hire me because
they really want my my view right you
know because um
there's something i did in either a
sample or the way i pitched an idea to
them that they felt like yeah this you
know this guy can really contribute so
um
so it's that creative flow that i told
you about that's fully there when i'm
doing spec work
and
it's
it's playing well with others in a
sandbox it's really kind of that simple
and there's a whole complication to it
but it really is that simple so um
uh and and i guess the other thing is
that there's
a piece with the sort of freelance
nature of it the feast and famine the
busy and then the flow and then and the
the paradox is the more relaxed you are
about
when projects come when doors close and
how you respond to them um
the easier things happen
and the times in my career when i was
like hey sex i got to make it happen i
was inadvertently pushing it away
you know it's like the um the cool kid
in high school you know this person is
like you know he you know all the guys
liked him the girls liked him he was he
wasn't doing anything he was just kind
of cool you know and so um we all have
that cool person inside us um and maybe
some of you were that cool and the funny
is if you talk to one of those people um
they might not make they might not even
have seen themselves as the cool person
but like um
but there absolutely is that part of all
of us that has that sort of charisma our
own authentic charisma and when we show
up
with that part of ourselves in a meeting
in the um the outreach part of the game
um where we're there's no desperation
we're not boring we're just um at ease
and we're ourselves what ends up
happening is we're um
it's about connecting dots so that we
make ourselves the exact dot that we
want to be and then the buyer of the
script is the exact they're looking for
that dot and then that's how they
connect so um
yeah i don't know if that makes sense it
does and i want to talk more about law
of attraction and things later um yeah
and and you had some great videos on
your channel about that as it relates to
story
what if things aren't so joyous
and you know that in in terms of staying
with a project and playing well in the
sandbox there are going to be times
where you're challenged and maybe you
didn't think of that before when you
were at nyu because it was all fun and
everybody was sort of
you were in this together and you could
have drinks afterwards or whatever it
was you knew each other well
but now the stakes are different how do
you how do you view it now because
things don't always go well in sandbox
yeah so um well my experience at nyu was
was awesome and very competitive um at
least because i'm a bit of a person so
maybe i was bringing that to it um so it
was it was lots of fun and it was a
great experience but it was you know
there was actually about half the people
there were kind of still figuring stuff
out and then the other half were kind of
killers and they were they were getting
after it um
so um
to me that side of it those pressures
were were similar but to your point
that's different like you know nyu is
like we paid the money we get the thing
that's it in the marketplace it's like
we put up or we don't get employed you
know what i mean so so there's those
pressures
that are really different but ultimately
it's it's the same game it's like
i either have
an idea that's going to contribute to
this producer's vision of what they want
to do with the project
or don't and so um when i show up and
have a meeting and share my take on
something or um
or they've already hired me and i do a
draft it's like i just i don't can do
the best that i can do and then um
they look at it and and then we go from
there i mean it's um so it's
so yes the the doors close um
and oftentimes people will
frame that situation of a closed door as
a challenge or terrible or this or that
or the other and um i understand that
and i have empathy for that and it's
just um
it's paying attention to the wrong thing
and it's actually a self-imposed
limitation to kind of even think of it
that way you just say um
you just count the wins you know this is
a win this is a win this is a win and
then the winds stop at some point but
like
um and it sounds like pollyanna-ish
because it is and yet um
as i've tried that sort of mindset it's
just hey it feels better it's real fun
and it works better because
again you're shifting to that cool kid
in high school everything's just it says
okay you work it out it's either this
okay yeah this door closed doesn't
matter there's one behind it and then
okay that one goes fine then there's one
behind it and the more we focus on that
it really does the paradox is the more
we're not attached to when the door
finally opens the faster they open
the watch pot never boils kind of that's
right
it absolutely never boils in hollywood
you cannot be desperate and you can't be
boring um and so
uh
the way to not be desperate and the way
to not be boring is the way to not be
boring is being authentic to yourself
and the way to not be desperate is
realize that it's okay it's gonna work
out
the universe is on the job you do you do
your stuff i go up i i make the best
creative choices i can i'm either i'm
specking material i'm working with this
partner or whatever and um and that's it
it's going to work out
did you always think like this
no
not at all that was the thing so um i
was always i always loved it right and i
loved it and i was very productive
there's some people that have like a
motor and they go and go and go and
that's sort of how my
sort of you know i made 50 short film
experiments before i even got to nyu and
then um at nyu a ton more right so i was
just i could just go
and um
i would what most people do
see what's going on out there
and
if things were going well i would feel
good if things were not going well the
door closed i would feel bad right so um
and that is a terrible way to live in
general i mean the way most people do it
in a sense because um
it hooks us into
the roller coaster and this business is
very much
that sort of cyclical up down there's
there's these things happening beyond
what we can completely control
so um
so what i would do
is you know hustle and get excited and
kind of effort my way this that and you
know i could make things happen and
things were good and i would progress
but the progression of my career
literally happens so much faster when
i'm i'm focused and i have a goal and i
know where i'm going but i'm not um i'm
i'm just not hooked into it it's gonna
happen or it's not this is gonna be i'm
just i'm i'm good with whatever happens
and it's um
and it's a practice you have to be able
to practice that in little ways and in
big ways and as i in my career was able
to practice that more often
a
my existential experience of life got
better i just felt better about me
and um and milestones got
crossed just much faster this milestone
that most and all it was easy no effort
everything's easy um and it's it's a
practice and so um
yeah so back in the day i didn't know
any different so i didn't i didn't know
to do it that way and i have a
a an accountability partner
who's who's a
professional tv writer and i remember a
few years ago he said he got this job
writing on the show and he was like yeah
you know there was no effort it was so
easy i just um
you know i didn't have to chase it down
and my mind was kind of hurting so
what do you mean what what's wrong with
this i spent my whole life hustling and
making things happen and he just
i realized that he was
in this place where
he was a valuing not hustling not
efforting letting things be easy
and i didn't realize that was possible
and if it was possible that it could
actually work
and it could work it actually felt
better and so in talking to him and then
reading a lot and
you know this is sort of law of
attraction stuff and you know
you know not getting caught up in some
of the woo-woo aspect of those things
but really looking at the tangible more
grounded aspects of them and then trying
them and as i tried them everything got
better i it felt felt better
i enjoyed it more my creative process
got
easier more powerful more consistent
my job became
i get up and i'm happy
and um
and then oh yeah what's going on out
there and uh is secondary you know what
i mean and it's again it's not 100 i'm
not like all rainbows and butterflies
but um
if you talk to people that i work with
um
they'll pretty much say that most of the
time
i'm feeling pretty happy and balanced
and and it's because i'm in the habit
i'm in the habit of whatever whatever um
whatever happens to me out there i
respond in a way
that just um
is aware of the of the sort of the
abundance and the bigness and the
greatness that's there around some of
the challenges and
you know the pieces of the challenges
does that make sense it does and balance
is something that's very important to
you this is sort of the scales
it is it is i you know um
yeah i would say yes certainly certainly
flow is the word that comes up for me
that when i'm in a state of flow
that's when it's easy it's effortless
it's just fun and it's like you get that
time warp experience
where
you played a lot of sports did you have
to retrain yourself because you said
before that you were competitive
is that helpful uh i love that you
brought up sports because um i've been
so i played soccer in college i was
captain of the nyu team and intensely
competitive
um
and
nyu is a division three school so
division one schools are like they're
all about it and division three schools
are students that also play right so but
i wanted to study the film school so i
was there but i was really competitive
too so um
uh this idea of how much
winning
matters and how to um
sort of make sense of winning in the
scope of things and and how to
it it absolutely fascinates me and it
completely relates to this whole idea of
mindset because again the same paradox
that we talked about with hollywood it's
like if you're too desperate for
something you're actually pushing it
away
and in sports if you're too desperate
for hitting a free throw shot or
something happening in soccer or
whatever it is you can't you have you
got to be loose and you got to have that
flow it's this it's exactly the same
thing and that's actually one of the
ways i was able to sort of
find value in the law of attraction
ideas um
you know and sort of just you know not
not pay too much attention to the
metaphysical parts of it because they
might be true but if it's metaphysical i
can't really sort of measure it or make
sense of it but i knew damn sure that
when i played sports if my mindset was
confident and easy and active and
flowing
the numbers my stats were much better
than if i was freaked out or if i was
worried about outcome what if we lose
what if i miss what if hollywood doesn't
come walking right so it's all the what
ifs what ifs and so
um it absolutely was a direct connection
for me to sort of take what i learned as
an athlete and then what i because i've
also coached a lot of kids in in sports
as well my own kids and i even coached a
high school soccer team for
a season which was amazing and um
i love that mindset stuff it just makes
it makes a big difference
certainly in sports absolutely
entertainment and really it crosses over
pretty much anywhere
should a new writer look at writing as a
fun endeavor or should they really check
themselves in the beginning and say okay
is this something i want to take on the
time commitment
time away from maybe friends and family
maybe there are going to be parts that
won't be so joyous
it's a great question and
yeah
absolutely do it because it's fun
there's no other reason to do it
and if it's not completely fun
do anything else you know find what is
fun for you
if there was something that was a hobby
for you that you love but you didn't
want to take it on as
a career
could you say the same for writers maybe
they just want to write for the sheer
joy of it for creating characters but
they don't want the pressure of having
to pitch and have
to pay their car payment based on
whether they sell a script or not yeah
of course yeah yeah no that's um
one of the most satisfying experiences i
get from
writing
yeah the fact that i get paid well to
write is separate from my experience of
of writing i mean if i didn't make a
dime from anything i wrote the rest of
my life i would still write i mean it's
because it's it's so
deeply
satisfying in terms of
executing my
vision for how life occurs to me what
are my deepest challenges what are my um
what are the insights that have sort of
gotten me through different parts of my
life how do i how did i
make a transformation from this stage to
that stage i mean that's what we do in
any screenplay and if i'm writing about
an astronaut or this or that
you know i've never been an astronaut
but i've written about several
but it's the emotional journey of those
characters that's it's as personal to me
as if i'm writing in a journal so um
if somebody is drawn to screenwriting
for the sheer joy of it that's
absolutely what they should be doing and
they and nobody really should be
worrying about the money side of it if
it's
so fun
for you to write a screenplay and so fun
for you to share it with anybody
and so fun for them to say i love it and
so fun for
them to sort of give you feedback and so
fun for you to take that feedback and
find a way to serve them even better and
so fun to keep that going then
absolutely that person should allow the
professional part of it to come to them
and if they stop at any point in that
path and they're happy just writing it
for themselves and showing it to nobody
that's great i mean it's really about
what makes them happy
is that the litmus test is it fun yeah
really so is that how you approach most
things in life though it has to be where
it's not creating huge amounts of stress
for you yeah um
absolutely i've read a wonderful book
years ago about
ben and jerry's ice cream company um i
love i loved it so much i cried when i
finished uh reading it and it was
because they to my mind um had a
beautiful vision of fun and business you
know it's show and its business and the
way they articulated it was this double
bottom line anything they did had had to
be fun and it had to be profitable right
and the truth is
if you approach it the right way
you absolutely can do both and if you're
not seeing the way to do both have
something be profitable and lucrative
and fun and easy you're not looking in
the right direction it's probably like
right behind you and you have to turn
around and look someplace else but it
really is and how
in my writing process or my life
certainly things come up and it feels
there's a resistance or something's not
easy
and then that's just a reminder to go
dude it's you know you're this is you're
forcing it it's too much and then i go
okay well what's the easy what's the
easy way what's the easy way and that's
oftentimes stopping and breathing or
we're not thinking about it think about
something else that is easy in the
moment and then going to that
and then
um
when i hold those spaces open the easy
ways come
have you had people challenge you
students mentees that say work isn't
supposed to be fun aside from this
interview where i'm
playing the devil's advocate
i love it well it's um
i mean that's the standard right so um
and and and
so it's where and and people are
people have to
i can sit here and tell them this or
that or the other and uh they
they need to figure it out for
themselves and they need to try it if
they're interested and not try it if
they're not interested it's not right
for them if they hear it and it's too
crazy and and you know then that's fine
so um i have no interest in um
convincing
somebody of anything i mean if i you
know when i used to teach this class
that you said ucla extension
i would absolutely speak to these ideas
um
and
they wouldn't really challenge me i'm
sure some people were very skeptical and
some people were flat out like that's
crazy that can't work and that's fine
you know it certainly can't work for
them if that's the way they think
um and
it might work for you even if you're
skeptical if you try it and you say okay
i think it's probably not going to work
but i'm going to be open to it and and i
i might try it and you see and what will
happen at least in my experience is
um
a it feels better and if nothing else if
the uh if there's no law of attraction
if it's all hui and um the odds of
something happening are exactly the same
but your approach to life feels better
and you've got the same odds it's worth
doing it so my invitation to anybody
who's skeptical is i honor the
skepticism try it out see if you enjoy
it more see if the odds are at least the
same of getting what you want as soon as
you want
and and see if you don't have the
experience that i've had and i've seen
pretty much everybody that embraces the
theory have you actually get things
faster
because
i'm
open to opportunities in a way that's
different when i'm closed off and i'm
focused on oh crap this is going to
happen i'm scared of that or this didn't
happen or i'm not good enough or i'm an
imposter or all these things these
voices that come up
um
you know it's good to notice that
they're there and just let them go and
if we spend too much time on them or we
just went anytime just just notice them
like the wind and let it go through
because the more we sort of give them
attention the more we're sort of
limiting ourselves
so you're also not attached to other
people's opinions it sounds like too
which is a beautiful place to be it's
the best place to be because um
my i'm here to serve my audience so um
if i have
um
you know so so you know i'll have a
bunch of ideas in my script that i've
put down and when i get feedback
i'm it's not me getting feedback it's
like these ideas came to me they're in
service to the audience and my job is to
sort of get out of the way it's whatever
the best idea from anywhere to better
serve the audience
and so when i get feedback and criticism
if there's any peace in that that's
going to be more of service to the
audience awesome and if it's not going
to be in service okay fine thanks for at
least you know trying to give me
feedback you know so
uh does that answer your question it
does yeah
how did the book save the cat change
your life oh it made a huge impact on my
life because up to the point where i
picked up that book i was muscling my
way through a writing process i'd taken
robert mckee's course and a bunch of
others and i liked it i love theory it's
fascinating to me and i went down where
you filmed school so i got nothing but
theory there um
and uh
and i'd made i think
i just finished like the fifth
feature screenplay that i wrote and that
one was the third independent feature
that i made
and it was um
it was another personal drama and it was
good for what it was but it was this
sort of self-imposed ceiling that i put
on my career it was um
i loved the subject matter and i'm proud
of it but it was so obscure that um it
just all the real greatness of those
ideas were not as accessible as they
could be had i sort of reordered the
ideas or built them in a different way
and so i finally this is probably my
mid-thirties i i um
got the humility to say okay maybe
hollywood knows a few things about story
structure that i should actually figure
out and again i've taken these other
courses but mckee is great but he's so
certain his theories are all these
different really cool pieces but there
was no system at least that i could get
from his his sort of uh weekend lecture
but i liked it i think i might have done
twice in my 20s
blake snyder's system to me was an
absolute
life changer game changer completely
because he has his own genre system he's
got his own um
step-by-step process um and uh and and i
took his after i loved the book i took
his weekend seminar and his energy was
delightful just playful fun really
accessible super smart
so i learned from him personally i
learned from his theory and i still use
it now and so it just it completely
revolutionized the way that i
think about concept think about
structure think about process i mean
it's a night and day difference and what
i use now and what i when i mentor
writers what i help them with is a
variation of of blake's system
that i've tailored to my own sort of
professional process and it's just a
step-by-step process of really focusing
on those story design choices because
what most writers will do is they'll go
i got an idea for a movie and maybe
they'll have a character or two or
whatever and then they jump ahead to um
writing the script
and now you're writing the script they
write like try to write the final draft
of the script and it's a fiasco that
process
is so difficult to get right and again
everybody has their own process so
that's the one you're using and it's
working for you great
in my experience
for my own work and working with a lot
of writers um
it's it's there's just so many missed
opportunities um
from focusing i break it down into seven
steps be similar to to blake's system so
i it's a simple way to say it is i tell
the story i get them to tell the story
or do my own work in one sentence and
then five sentences and then 15
sentences which is like blake's 15 beats
and then 40
sentences which is basically a sentence
for each
scene in the movie more or less
those are the first four steps and then
the other three are screenplay draft
steps so you have get it down get it
good and get it great
um and and it's and it's a problem all
those those things are they're steps but
they're really
almost like um
there's seven different ways the
audience is craving answers about your
story and most writers that aren't like
fully firing on all pistons aren't
answering those questions as deeply as
they could so i'm good at doing that in
my work at least enough and then i get
feedback and i figure out how to do it
even better and when i work with other
people i just make sure that they're
fully answering those questions and then
when they get to the screenplay writing
part um
get it down as just as quickly as you
can
you're almost like formatting it i
usually tell like write a treatment in
that fourth stage after i do like the 40
sort of sentences for each scene i'll
kind of write that into a treatment five
pages 15 pages and that was copy and
paste that into the screenplay format
and then i'm just almost reformatting it
cliche this cliche that doesn't matter
bomb but just kind of scaffolding
that's that that that um
step um five and then step six is get it
good it's not great it's just kind of
okay you got a mess of cliches and
whatever but you kind of organize it a
little bit just kind of easy breezy
momentum flow
and then after a few drafts of that
you're like okay this is working you're
getting good feedback
again we're in the reaction game so it's
not enough if you want to be
professional
that um that i dislike it's like i have
to like it and then it's coming across
other people and they're saying it's
great um and then when you're getting
that good then you get into that fine
tuning safe get it get it great so it's
gonna get it down get it good get it
great and what i see most mistakes they
make so this is that seven step process
inspired by blake's people will get a
loose idea right here like step one and
it'll jump to like step seven and it's a
fiasco
and even if they finish the script um
you can see it the script's is a mess
and sometimes
you know if they tell me what their
script idea is in one sentence
um
it'll it'll also be a mess and i can
just like just by seeing the one
sentence i know the same problems they
have in a hundred page script
when you say some new writers aren't
good at providing answers to questions
about their characters is it because
they themselves don't know the answers
or they're not good at relaying that
information
um to the audience almost everybody just
hasn't thought about it enough
um i mean there's some people that have
a laser bead on who these people are and
and um and they're just and they're sort
of developing their skill in terms of
articulating on that page with pagecraft
um but most of the people just um it's
just a little fuzzy they haven't spent
enough time going wait a minute who is
that character um
for example i'm writing this this this
script right now and um
it was interesting because i had this
problem with sort of the plotting in the
first act and i couldn't quite
work it out and i was you know i was
like well tried to figure out this and i
tried to figure out that way i couldn't
do it and then taking my own advice i
was like oh just relax and do something
else what is easy now so i went over to
this and i was getting this note from
this one character and they were like
who's this guy why what is he doing and
i was like oh yeah you're right he's i
kind of had a sense of him but how can i
sort of clarify it sharpen the focus on
him
and then when i did um
i was like oh i know this guy and he's
he's great he's so swarmy and he's just
he's almost like this
paul giamatti type character and i was
like oh he's so fun to write and then
once i got that clarity i realized oh i
need a new scene in the first act for
this guy because i had it previously
happening off screen but once i got more
clarity on who that character was i
added that scene and then magically it
took care of that plot issue that i
couldn't get before
so that's a real world example of how i
totally used the easy way to solve
something i was using it the hard way at
first i tried it this way tried it this
way and i then was like oh dude yeah no
there's an easy way don't force it and i
just went over to something else and was
like okay and then
boom
would you say before you read save the
cat or took some of blake snyder's
courses that you were bad at structure
that's a great question i just had a
very rudimentary
beginning middle and end sense of
structure and i
the problem is i had kind of too many
halfway ideas about it you know this
guru that guru the other and i i
remember one time i made the spreadsheet
probably i was in my 20s i'd probably
written two or three and i was it was
literally like 50 or 60 boxes and like
this question and that question and it
was just a mess of like there was no
connective tissue to it so when i found
blake snyder's system
which had
really deep
actionable insights about why movies
from hollywood work
and a system step by step to sort of
move through it
it just it all came together for me
how do you teach structure to your
students i teach structure to my
students
generally starting with blake's method
so um
we talk about concept we talk about um
uh five story well blake talks blake
goes from concept to 15
what he calls beats
but they're not even really beats it's
um
he's what he'll have is in his 15 beats
are
there's some turning points and there's
sequences
um and then he's got opening image
closing images which is a great
bookending device and then he calls out
your b story which is your second most
significant thread and then he um he
talks about the theme
how it should be stated early on and
overtly
um
and and that's it so there's a few
things that are um
but it's kind of a weird word so i i
kind of think of his sort of 15 story
but they're all pertinent it's like i
for sure am writing a better screenplay
when i have good answers for each of
those 15 things whatever you want to
call them
the thing one of the things i added to
to my process that he doesn't really
talk about is
starting with you know the log line and
premises is huge and then 15 beats is
really helpful but in between those two
there's i i do five sentences so act one
act two a or what blake calls fun and
games your midpoint turn
and then act two b and then act three
um so it's more or less the three-act
structure but it's broken out into these
pieces i mean this is a turning point
but like it's so important to kind of
call it out and so sometimes when i'm
even coming up with a movie idea for the
in the very beginning i'll kind of have
a couple pieces of the concept and i'll
actually maybe sketch it out the five to
five sentences but it's all easy it's
kind of like well oh i know it's going
to end and i'm not quite sure about this
part of that part so i just fill in what
i know and go to the other parts and
just kind of play with it and then it
just comes together
if it's a good idea and if it's easy
it'll come together and if it's not
coming together at least right now i
just put it aside do something else that
is easy
and then you said if to further flesh it
out 40 you you do like you number one
through 40 and then you have one
sentence be each scene
that's right so for that like that's my
step four process right it'll um and
most movies will have about 40 scenes
you know plus or minus 5 or 10 or
whatever so um i want to get a sense of
i'll expand those 15 beats to like the
40 scenes and if it's 35 i don't care
it's fine i just note oh i'm a little
bit short because here's the thing the
thing with structure that throws off a
lot of people is
especially people that aren't
comfortable with it yet they're like i
don't want to follow those rules it's
confining me
and they use that exact tone of voice
so but what
what's most instructive to me and how i
also work with with um you know my
mentees or students or whatever i um
it's the expectations of the audience
the audience is absolutely
craving uh beginning middle and end
they're craving your your break into act
two to happen someplace around you know
the late 20s you know 25 minutes 20 you
know blake says 27 minutes so it doesn't
have to be on that page but um but if i
write it and it's five pages after that
or ten pages i'm aware of that and it's
the opportunity to go i know the
audience is expecting this around 27
do i have enough legit have i earned
their trust to go longer
am i so it's totally fine to sort of go
against their expectations
but i want to do it mindfully
or it's an opportunity to go huh
i'm you know my i'm breaking into two at
that you know page 35
is there something i can oh you know
what i totally can cut this whole scene
or trim this down and then i get it
closer so it's an opportunity to very
definitively look at what the audience
is expecting in a very concrete way and
go do i want to play two audience
expectations here or go against it so
specifically with the 40
you know 40 sentences for the scenes you
know again plus or minus five or ten or
whatever um
i'll do that and then i i um so i so i
have the sort of bone structure of how i
can go and i often put them on index
cards and a board in my my home office
and um
and uh and then i'd like to go from
there before i go to the script to
actually write a treatment as well for
two reasons one is um
the uh those 40 cards are really good
for sort of structural choices and sort
of thread flow and that sort of thing
but they don't get the feeling really of
the story so that's why i go to a
treatment and then the second reason is
you know nobody's going to look at my 40
beats and really get what i'm doing so
if i want feedback and i get a lot of
feedback in the treatment stage
i write the treatment and then i can you
know five pages 10 pages whatever it
takes the screenplay that i'm working on
now i actually did three drafts of the
treatment got really good feedback
between everyone then realized that i
wanted to change the protagonist from
one character to the other
and then did three more drafts of the
treatment and then felt it was good and
then i'm into the screenplay so by the
time i get to the screenplay my first
draft
you know it's not really a first draft
because i've spent so much time
designing the story doing the treatment
it's it's
by probably a typical you know
fifth draft or tenth draft for other
people
at what point should a writer have
earned the audience's trust and if it's
not there by that point
it's going to be hard to get it later
page one
um
you know um
i mean i'll look at a screenplay and
literally
line one i'm already going really does
this person have the job i can't look i
can't look at one line and definitively
say but i but i'll tell you what
you give me you show me the first
sentence or maybe not it can't be just
the slug line the slug line in one
sentence of um
you know
you should it was interesting but if i
saw the slug line in one sentence of 10
screenplays
i bet you
i could tell you how much i'm going to
like that screenplay
um within probably 80 percent likelihood
like i can see a professional crafted
line in just two sentences um i don't do
that
that harshly whatever like you know at
least give them a page or two if i'm
gonna sort of evaluate something but
like um
there's just so many choices i mean
you're talking it's
it's sort of like poetry in a sense
where every word counts and you can
often when you've done it for so long
realize i don't need that word i don't
need that word i could subtract to
subtract you get that white space
flowing on the page so you can um
just very efficiently
and then
muscular word choices and specific words
there's so much to be seen again so i'll
even say this if you take a if you take
even the way the slug line is formatted
and the way they're talking about the
time of day and those things those are
choices and um
and amateurs tend to make one pool of
choices and professionals tend to make
other ones again tendencies but like
yeah i would think 80 of the time i
could look at two lines and i could feel
like this is probably a professional or
somebody at least writing at the
professional level
and so
if that page one is not
is not up to par it's going to be very
difficult almost impossible maybe to
gain that trust
for the reader or audience later on so
yes but it's not binary right so what
will happen is um
you know all
anybody who's spending the hours and
hours of time writing a screenplay has
some sort of talent you know i mean they
have something going on right so you
know i don't think i've ever read a
screenplay that had like zero like
nothing right there's something you know
so um
but what will happen is i'll get to page
one if i was just picking up a random
script from random amateur writer and i
look at page one
again i look at line two or three and
i'm already knowing yeah this person's
probably you know from the scale of
totally professional to total beginner
within two sentences i know that okay
this is probably where this person is
and i'll get to the end of the first
page and now i have a 90 chance or 95
chance of knowing where they are now
that being said if i'm a production
company and i'm looking for a thriller
and my friend said he read he read this
thriller and it was amazing and i read
page one and i'm going okay
my friends i trust my friend he's saying
it's amazing i'm looking at this thing
it's not a really a professional level
written thing it's kind of amateurish i
might not toss in the trash at that
point i might go um okay but you're it's
it's
you're leaning against it you're sort of
you're minimizing it so it's important
not to see it in a binary way where it's
this or that but at a certain point in
hollywood it will be binded they'll give
you first of all they're not going to
read the script unless in one sentence
you can pitch the story
and then they'll go oh yeah that's worth
my time then they'll give it a couple
pages and then toss it when it's not any
good
it's more than just formatting issues
though you said it's also like word
choices
and
you know it's not just how much white's
on the page or even
it's all those things right because it's
the screenplay format is so um
it's kind of
clunky it's a clunky format right um
you know uh the way the slug line works
and it just it's sort of
yeah i mean whereas pros it's just like
a waterfall of words you know and i
don't even write prose but like um
but the screenplay format is just it's
blocky
and so
because there's those limitations
um
when you get really familiar with the
format you can see people
very quickly making choices within this
sort of format that are
you know different good or different bad
or or different inexperienced you know
there was a script a specser that came
out a couple years ago that was doing
all sorts of crazy things with fonts and
craziness and um
i love a little of that when it's
organic and it feels inspired um
but this script i i you know i wanted to
ring somebody's neck after about 30
pages i was like you know oh wow cool
idea and i like it because they were
really stretching the bounds of the
format um and then it felt like to me it
was a
it was
at least to me for my sensibility was it
felt like a trick or a gimmick it wasn't
that they um
to my mind i wasn't able to find my way
in emotionally to what their vision was
you know so um
so i don't know i mean um but they you
know certainly made a splash doing that
and um and who knows maybe other people
really liked it then that's that's great
that's the thing is it's a subjective
business so um you know i have very
refined and and strongly held
beliefs but i'm just one opinion you
know i mean we you know we might
disagree about what won the oscar in any
given year you love it i hate it or vice
versa and that's a movie that's produced
and heralded as the best that we've got
and stark disagreements so um certainly
any spec script
by any writer
um you know it just needs to be i mean
if i'm working with somebody i'm
what's interesting about that is if i'm
working with somebody my opinion doesn't
even really come up because it doesn't
matter my what i do is or even when i
write my own stuff it's
i'm an advocate for their audience
and i gently in an inspired way just
ask questions when i think that their
audience is going to be wondering you
know
why you know i think your audience is
going to want a more cohesive idea here
you know what if like you're all i know
your audience is craves to have a sense
of irony in your concept
you know i know your audience might you
know when you're thinking about
constructing your log line they want a
character's goal that is just driven
it's powerful and there's these stakes
and then there's a conflict
so i just
sort of i articulate what i'm in my
experience i believe their audience is
going to be thinking and that gives the
people i work with
um a really fine
sort of
goal post for them to
shoot at and that's the great thing is
that um
whenever you whatever your writing
process is or whatever your support
system is
you you want to have a really high
quality feedback loop so you can stay
focused on the task at hand in an
inspired way and move as quickly as
possible what slows up writers is they
don't have a quality feedback loop
system they kind of figure out their own
they might read a book but they can read
a book and they don't know if they're
actually applying the book or not um and
then they might have all sorts of
hang-ups about getting feedback because
this person yelled at them they take
toxic or they or their you know they
take too much feedback and they drown
her out their own voices all sorts of
nightmares but like having a world-class
um feedback and development system is
absolutely
one of the best things i've done for my
career um i mean and i'm so good at it i
can even i can even take to somebody
that's like a layperson that doesn't
even know the business
and i can ask them
for feedback in a certain way
and it gives me a high quality echo of
what's going on if you just hand them if
i hand my sister the script and my
sister's awesome and uh she used to
always watch our high school movies and
she has belting laughs
we called her like the laugh anchor but
anyway but in general if i was to give
her my script
and she would basically say oh i liked
it or i didn't like it right that's sort
of base level analysis um
but what you can do
is take even a lay person if you direct
them in the right way with how you ask
for feedback
so you know uh you know for my sister i
could say was there any um what was your
favorite character
was um which character do you feel like
you wanted to know more about or needed
more sort of development
which scenes felt like you didn't need
them right these are
questions she absolutely can answer
um
definitively from her opinion and she
would have almost never thought to
tell that to me if i just gave it to her
because she's a lay person right she's
just going oh i like this line of
dialogue or this was great or i didn't
like it or whatever so um
so
whatever writers use for their feedback
system whether i have a writer's group
or a coach or accountability partner or
whatever works for them
i would invite them to have it be a
really high quality
echo because we're anticipating we're in
the reaction business we're anticipating
that reaction from the audience and the
better that feedback loop can be and the
quicker it can be the faster our career
will move forward
what do you say to screenwriters who are
insulted or feel that it's too rush or
you're not respecting the craft when you
can tell by page one or even really
halfway down the page whether it's a
professional level screenplay what do
you say to those people um
it's a great question and i know a lot
of writers um feel very strongly about
that like how could you even tell my
screenplay is any good if you've only
read you know you know one page or even
a couple lines that's really ridiculous
um
okay
no
i'm fine uh you can disagree with me all
you want um i believe i
am familiar enough
with this stuff
um and i see patterns and indicators of
success and i see a correlation
um
you know and i and i believe it and not
only in me
every experienced right every like 100
percent of the not 100 maybe 95 98 of
experienced writers that i know
absolutely feel like
again it's not binary they can't read a
line or a page and go this is
definitively crap or definitely good but
you know
you know all my peers i i absolutely
would put money on them
looking at a particular random script
and after reading one page
they all for sure
could say this is an amateur level
writer or this is a you know probably
not even 100 but i think for the most
part and it's just because there's
what i think the people they get upset
about is they don't
they don't know what they don't know
they don't realize how many choices
they're making on the page
and that's probably why they get pissed
off is because
they're going okay the character gets in
the car or and such and such happens but
right but like
you know i've written 25 30 screenplays
so i've and and that's just like
finished ones not to mention some of
those drafts were 15 20 30 drafts and
probably another 30 treatment so like
i've been in the game for a while i've
seen a lot of stuff and
and you just get familiar with the same
thing over and over and over again so um
so what they so a a person writing their
first second third screenplay for them
they're just focusing on basic oh
there's a guy i see him in the car and
they just say guy gets in the car
but like
you know i'm seeing that same line and
i'm thinking of on 10 levels you know
i'm thinking of it on how many words the
how muscular the words are the cadence
what's going on before that and after um
you know how um
you know uh
symbolically how does it relate to the
theme you know and again i don't do all
that on the first draft but by the time
i get to that end draft
every line i've thought about dozens and
dozens of times with those different
lenses
and because i have
that much familiarity with every single
line in my screenplay
um i can read a line from an amateur
who's probably looked at that line two
times three times five times
and when i look at something two times
five times it's like that it's not
really it does you know it looks like a
rough rock it doesn't look like a gem
when i've seen something a dozen times
20 times especially after all my
experience
it shines in a different way you just
the magic comes through it in a way
that's different so um
even if you were to look at you know my
first draft and my last draft
you're just seeing a rougher edge with
all those things and that's just part of
the process and that's another thing is
that a lot of um
amateur writers they won't do as many
drafts as they need to to really shine
or they'll do the drafts but they're
changing the wrong damn things that
don't even make a difference
which kind of breaks my heart because um
they've got enough creativity and they
love it enough but they don't
know the way through the forest so they
end up spending years and years
wandering around and then some of them
quit it's terrible
can you give me an example of of poorly
used cadence
um
so poorly used that's an interesting
question poorly used cadence
in dialogue would be something that
doesn't sound authentic to that
character right usually it's the
writer's own voice
they all sound like you know me and you
know what the truth is um
i am fine writing my early drafts pretty
much with everybody my in my in my voice
i mean why not i mean if i have an ear
for them fine i'll do it but like even
if the thing i'm writing now has this
british character and you know i'm doing
kind of a
you know whatever loose idea of a
british i'll imagine like a guy from
hell's kitchen or like pierce morgan
what do you say but like i don't sweat
it it's sort of like it's more like me
kind of doing a bad british accent or
whatever you know that's kind of the
cadence that i'm hearing and then as i
get to draft drafts i'll maybe bring in
a friend who's british and go dude can
you take a look at this and he'll go
yeah we would never say this we would
never do that you know or like when i
was writing astronauts it was great to
um get real astronauts and go um yeah we
described this stuff and we're kind of
like pulling it off stuff we got on the
internet i don't you know do tell me and
it was really exciting every time
they're like no no that's legit that's
right i was like wow it is it's amazing
so um
cadence for a line of
description
is really where your voice comes from as
a screenwriter um you know hemingway
very classically had this very simple
sort of style
um there's most of the screenwriters on
the that make the blacklist every year
have a pretty
visceral sense of their voice so if you
look at
you pick three scripts from the
blacklist and you look at their first
couple lines on their first page you're
going to probably see slight differences
in cadence
in the way they
they talk and it's just you feel it it's
weird because it's it's
cadence is different it's a rhythmic
thing um uh and you know word choice
plays part of it but it's just sort of a
it's a rhythm
i think the first time i thought about i
learned about that sort of thing was um
spike lee
um
one of his books you know his first you
know how i made this how i made she's
gotta have it whatever that book was but
it was um i read the book and i was like
oh this is exactly the way spike talks
and like interviews and stuff and i was
like oh you can do that you're not
supposed to write this kind of fakey
fake format that you learn in school and
it was like and it was so
it just felt more personal you know so i
think
screenwriters that have a great voice
they describe those action scenes with
um
not so much like so strongly there but
like there's a sense of their cadence in
this genre in service to this particular
story so i haven't read a spike
screenplay in a while
so i don't know exactly what he does on
the page but i would imagine it's i mean
the thing i read of his was nonfiction
so it was very much his voice but voices
is great it's probably one of the things
that um
again most of the scripts that make the
blacklist every year are are mostly
powerful in in voice
um
and then
somewhat in concept although some of the
concepts are not very strong
and then they can execute but i in my
ucla extension class we would often
teach a lot of those screenplays from
the blacklist and very interestingly
they um
the ratings were all over the board it
wasn't like you know i wouldn't tell
them which one's wrong sometimes i would
sometimes i wouldn't but like it didn't
matter there was literally
um some of the scripts they hated the
most the class blacklist scripts wow
it's it's there's so much subjectivity
in the business so you just have to
know how to
getting back to that feedback system you
know how to take subjectivity out of it
you need enough data points so that it's
not um one person is never making or
breaking you or one contest or one
whatever you need enough data points so
that um
subjectivity is not a significant factor
i think kevin smith too has a very
distinct cadence for his writing and in
his book and um that's right
when you talk about muscular words
can you give me an example of a weak
muscular word versus a strong one um
so um
muscular is sort of like the opposite of
um
pat you know passive to a passive active
is more different but you can say
passive or active and active even more
muscular so um we are talking
right it's a passive way in a very bland
way um
um we are
enthralled in conversation and maybe
that's even a little too flowery but
right but we are um digging into the
meat of the craft of screenwriting
you know you can feel the difference
between those different word choices and
the amateur will do things like we are
talking and and that's why you can see
it in one one sentence and then you
might have somebody who's getting look
again you know the other thing i said
about enthralled or whatever that might
be a little bit too flowery right um but
you'll see
the um the writers that have that voice
there's there's a poetry to it it's just
beautiful it's just enough
sort of
flourish on it's not too fancy or
sometimes it will be uh there was a guy
that wrote um
uh friday's name but he um anyway
any great screenwriter has really
distinct cadence and voice
if we posted a video entitled the
writing advice which changed my life
would it be save the cat or something
else um
for sure
if i had to pick one
most influential
theorist on my
career
by a long shot it was blake snyder
him personally and his system because i
read the book i was like wow this is
amazing i took his class
and i was like he's amazing
and um
it just was so robust and actionable and
easy and accessible and didn't take
himself seriously and just helpful and
it was like oh yeah it was this was how
i was trying to serve my audience and
he's got so many good ideas on how to
serve them better than i was taking what
i already did that was great and then um
making it more or sort of
allowing me to be more articulate in the
way that i was serving them and then um
a couple years after that that i took
his his seminar um
i had won this contest and part of um
winning that contest with this one
screenplay that i wrote with this other
writer
and he hadn't taken blake's seminar
class as he was so like oh and i did it
once and i was like i'll do it again and
that was actually after blake had died
unfortunately so i was curious about how
somebody else would teach his class and
my writing partner hadn't um
uh taken his seminar at all but we were
both using that system we're a fan so we
went back and and did it with another
instructor who was also wonderful it was
blake but he was wonderful
and interestingly the story that we
broke that weekend we actually sold we
set it up
how long did it take you to write it
well we broke you know his weekend
seminar because you go in with start
with a log line and you end with um your
15 beats at the end so um we broke the
sort of
the you know the structure of it then
and then we probably did i don't know
i'm sure a month or two of sort of
breaking it out and then
my guess is we probably had and then
lots of drafts it was probably after
that weekend probably three months
after that we probably had a draft we
had a producer attached to that already
and we were going to make that one
ourselves directed ourselves um but the
producer was like dude this guy this is
really good
we i think i can get this set up
someplace else and we said great so then
we um end up and that's the script that
got me assigned to uta and then we
started uh
taking around ended up getting set up
and uh that was great
how did you meet that producer
i went to nyu with him oh nice okay so
alumni pays off yeah uh it did in this
case it did in this case i mean my look
i
feel i have some strong mixed feelings
about nyu i generally experientially i
loved it um it was you know some of my
favorite times i have lots of favorite
times in my life but i i really enjoyed
it um
the cost of those programs generally
doesn't sort of
pay out the return on that investment to
me feels out of whack um
uh so
um
so there's that and people that are
doing undergrad probably you can justify
a little bit more but those mfa programs
are really expensive and um and people
if they have the money awesome that's
great um but if they're taking out those
loans for those programs that's a
heartbreaker because um
you know no matter how good you are
that's just a big burden uh so the
logistics of that is is i think um
really problematic
um
so uh
but i like the simple experience and
partly a lot of people talk about the
people that you meet there right so
if nothing else because it's you know
nyu is seen as some people consider it
the best film school certainly one of
the best um people are then attracted to
it for those reasons i want to go where
the best is right so so i met really
great people there and um
and so that made a big impact and this
was one producer that i did but the
truth is if i were to go back i wouldn't
go to film school if i was rich i
wouldn't be fine but i wouldn't because
i would have maybe hung out at sundance
and been a volunteer there and met those
same damn people that way or um you know
there's lots of different ways to meet
people which is important and that's
people say well film school you can meet
people great but like you're meeting
people and you're paying an arm and a
leg for it so um
there's there's other ways to meet
people that are
at that ambition level that that you
might be attracted to if you want to do
really sort of world-class work
which you'll get at usc nyu afi those
places um but there's other places to
meet those same people um and when you
show up
with your power or your superpower who
you are
you find people you find the right
people and the people that aren't your
type you just you know get filtered out
yeah and the thing for gen xers like you
and i is that social media wasn't around
crowdfunding wasn't around and it's so
valuable now because you can meet so
many people let's suppose you have a
successful campaign now you need an
editor you can find somebody another
country and and they can you know but
but those options weren't available at
that time a totally different world so i
mean you know your youtube channel is
one wonderful way of them you know
democratizing it i mean the information
you guys have one person after another
with these really great ideas um just
makes it so much more accessible for all
sorts of people um you know and makes
you know justifying the cost for those
really expensive
you know film programs especially the
mfa programs just you know again if
you've got the money it's awesome it's a
great one-stop shop and you can have
some forge some great memories that
you're you're not going to get other
places so you know in terms of making a
film together and
and watching it together so
if a writer is being ignored by
hollywood is that a sign that possibly
their work is just not ready yet maybe
it's a great question so um
there's two things going on here um most
likely they're probably not ready that's
that's more likely and
because subjective business it's
entirely possible that work is totally
ready and just hasn't found the right
person at the right time
so how do you know which one is you with
your script
that's when you come back to this idea
of a high quality feedback system right
so first your internal system with where
you're developing it and then when you
get it to the point where you feel like
it's as great as you can make it then if
you're an amateur
you go to screenplay contests or
blacklist.com or spec.tom and
specscout.com or coverfly really great
places to see where you stack up and the
metrics i generally suggest are
10 places it could be an industry
it could be somebody that works it could
be a friend of yours that's an intern at
such and such production company it
could be one of the contests it could be
one of those screenplays exchanges that
i just mentioned any of those things if
it's somebody in the industry that could
be like oh my god this is the best
script i ever read i'm going to turn
around and give it to so and so and they
could do something with it that to me
counts as an open door
if it's your friend who went to film
school with you that doesn't count
because unless that person's you know
spielberg's kid or something right so um
it's got to be somebody that has the
agency to sort of move it move it
forward
out of 10 data points whether they're in
every contest everyone is like cool
contest
every contest has an opportunity to
break your career they don't exist
they're there to try to help you right
you know there's one or two scams out
there but by and large they're trying to
help you they want your script to be
amazing so um
so
they're all data points so you if you
submit to 10 places in the industry
contest exchange whatever and at least
three out of the ten only three out of
the ten
you are
getting an open door
then you're actually in a good place
at that's the minimum right and by that
means an open door is you advance in
that contest you get maybe a seven on
the blacklist or you're pretty high in
the specs out but you're basically
you're getting to the point where either
that organization is like oh we want to
keep you listed on our site because we
feel like we might want to take credit
for your success right anybody advances
that's what they're doing if you
uh submit it to your friend who's
working at such and such and they submit
it up to the producer and like oh this
is interesting we're not going to set
this up but maybe you come in for a
general meeting or the next thing you
write right that's an open door anything
that's sort of that counts as like a
longer term relationship escalation
that counts if you don't get it if you
get um rejected by the screenplay if
blacklist gives you a three if whatever
if if it's a closed door um then it's
just a data point no big deal okay it's
a data point so when you then you look
at those data points and if you're not
getting
if you're only getting one or two out of
ten
you know it's probably because the
material is not close and then you go
back and you go okay well i thought it
was close here's what i'm doing here's
what my comparable movie's doing what's
the difference how do i close that gap
you close that gap by a high quality
feedback loop people that know what
they're doing people that'll give you a
sense and then you'll figure out and
then you go back and you resubmit right
if you are
getting
um more let's say you're you know five
at it like half you have a great script
and half the places you submit to you're
you're advancing or maybe you won one
outright right great so now you're in a
different place now you're for sure
ringing the bell and now it's a numbers
game that's when you double down
and i did this myself when i was first
starting out and entering contests we
had a script me and this one writing
partner and it made the quarterfinals of
the nicholl fellowship and i was like oh
that's nice so um i'm going to double
down 15 more screenplay uh contests to
that for that script right because i
already knew that it was proven
and and so then i had 16 data points and
what happened eight of them
were open doors of some sort and eight
of them nothing
and one of the things that breaks my
heart is like writers come up to me like
yeah you know i submitted my script like
two or three places and like you know i
only got into one or whatever but they
they don't they're not taking
subjectivity out of it you need data
points right so of that one script and
one of those scripts we won the grand
prize we run ten thousand dollars so
if our script we've submitted to three
of those places by chance and they all
got projected and we just gave up
this left ten thousand dollars on the
table right so
uh
so you got to take subject heavy
subjectivity out of it by getting enough
data points um and so uh
and then once you have
something that's again you're getting
you know fifty percent at least thirty
percent but you want fifty sixty seventy
percent of open door rate they need to
buy as many lottery tickets as you can
as many festivals as you can get that
there's also other ways you can
you meet anybody you want in hollywood
this idea that the doors are closed are
ridiculous because um all you need you
just need to
you need to know how to entertain your
way into talking to people i mean that's
the truth and there's way you know and
usually the way most people query
hollywood is ridiculous it's um
what you need to do is
empathize with where the other person is
and
approach them with an easy ask maybe you
ask them a question maybe you look at
their twitter account you see what
they're talking about but you have
um you have an organic conversation with
these people at peer-to-peer
and there's lots of the doors are wide
open this myth that it's closed is
ridiculous it's closed because you
haven't thought about them you've been
thinking about yourself and you don't
either don't have it in this on the
script yet you need to you know
spend more time developing the craft or
um you actually have a quality project
but you're selfish in the way that
you're um approaching people you're
annoying them you know you're like a
telemarketer or whatever
it's not gonna work you know but if you
charm your way
you know you can even there's a guy that
hit me up on twitter who um
he technically made all the wrong
decisions in terms of how to query i
tell people how to do it and when i work
with them and there's very specific ways
that have a very high success rate this
guy did all the wrong ways you know he
was completely talking about himself me
me me my project whatever but it was so
damn charming and the way he did it i
was like
i'll give him a pass i started talking
to him and you know we ended up you know
ended up working with him so
um
charm is the most important thing but
like and it can even overcome bad form
but like
there are just simple ways of again
getting back this idea of it all being
easy
you know people are like ah
i knew this one writer who thousands of
query letters and it was partly and got
like sort of no response and partly
because he um
he just had that old school approach i'm
just going to shotgun all these people
and i'm going to talk about all my i got
to establish credibility so i did this
and i won this festival blah blah blah
and it's just noise it's just noise
nobody wants to hear that but everybody
wants to have good conversations so
you want to talk to anybody in hollywood
look them up online see what they're
talking about get in organically get
into a conversation with them by talking
about what they're already tweeting
about on twitter or whatever their
charity is or whatever they already love
and let it be organic don't be attached
to it let it be easy and i guarantee you
if they are true kindred spirits you
will find something to talk about and
then at the right time they'll go wow
you're fascinating what are you working
on oh
glad you asked
and then you pitch
but can charm really be taught because
there's some really bright people around
here and maybe they're just so used to
being very matter-of-fact they're not
used to i hate to say bsing but
sometimes charm can be equated to bs and
there's a there's a there's a time for
that
and and and people can do it very subtly
and it works but some people don't
they're not they don't do charm yeah
what happens to those people um
so um
it's a good question and um it's it's
not buyer me but it's not binary there's
not you have it or you don't it's
there's a charmometer right
how far along you know and there's some
people that are off the charts that are
super charming and a lot of people in
hollywood are very charming in general
it's a business that attracts charisma
and sort of thing um
but for sure
there are ways we can allow that
charming charismatic side of ourselves
to be more present or less present it's
a choice it's a practice you can't just
some people can turn it on but some
people need more practice but um
it's everybody's got it whether you're
sort of geeky or bro or
artsy or whatever your thing is
um emo yeah it could be anything it
could be anything but like um
there's a side of you
that's authentic and a little vulnerable
and human and humble
and um when you show up in that energy
um
in service to somebody else again the t
i was the point that i was making before
is this guy was so charming that even
using the wrong form he got my interest
what i'm saying is you can actually just
even have average level charm and if you
use my my approach you're going to get
doors opening
easily if you've got the goods what
happens is most people
most people are asking me how do i try
out for the yankees i'm like oh you want
to try for the yankees huh what minor
league baseball team you're on oh miners
i have to do that first no no yeah dude
you can't you're not going to make the
yankees
first go try out for a minor league team
crush it in the minors now you have a
shot at the yankees but that's exactly
what i get when people are hitting me up
they're going well how do i i got i just
wrote a script how do i sell it i'm like
wow you might be able to sell it it
might be great why don't you submit to a
couple contests and see how you stack up
and maybe it is maybe it's the best
thing i've ever read but chances are if
it's the first thing you wrote the
second thing you wrote
you know you're not ready for the majors
yet probably and it's the same way it's
like if you wanna play baseball you
don't be like you know i was really good
in high school i'm gonna go play in the
majors i mean maybe some phenomenal
players can play at 18 but like
you know you
amateur writers don't realize levels and
they don't they don't quite realize that
they're they're competing against
professionals
you know professionals that are at the
game you know in in fact in the major
leagues
you know you've only got this short
window of time when you can play in the
majors right but like the professional
writing game you know you could be 20
years old you're competing against me
you're paying about 70 year olds you're
bringing the lead you're competing
against everybody that's alive and can
breathe and sort of think so it's a wide
pool and you have to bring your game
by understanding those levels and
understanding where you really are
and then moving forward and
it's not a bad thing it's not a big deal
to be like okay yeah i'm here and i'm on
this part of the road who cares because
you know what at some point if you stay
with it you will become professional and
okay that's fine and then um it's all
the process anyway so it really doesn't
matter that much
that
it doesn't matter that much
where you are along the road but for
damn sure it matters that
if you're at the early part of your
journey you're not thinking that you're
someplace else
you know and on the flip side after
you've won an oscar after you've had a
box office success after you've had
whatever
you can't then get so arrogant that
think that you know it all and you're
not still learning that's where that
sophomore slump comes in that's where
all that problem comes in it's the same
problem that the beginner has they're
not in the flow they're not feeling
their superpower and leading from their
superpower they're doing it enough to
get in and then they get some sort of
success and they stop doing it and they
fall off the cliff
explain to me data point
in terms of screenwriting so when i say
data point i just mean
the numbers so if you talk about going
to 10 places in the industry that has
the potential to advance your career
um
it's
you know it's a way calling it a data
point is a way of sort of draining out
the emotion of it because you know i was
helping with this one screenplay contest
once and it was amazing because somebody
did
this
the screenwriter um he didn't his script
didn't make it to the corner finals and
his response was go f yourself
oh
okay
it's just such a
such a ridiculous it's so ridiculous on
so many levels um
and to the point that i'm trying to make
here is it's ridiculous because um
it just
it's one data point it doesn't matter
when any screenplay you know contest
doesn't reject that you should the
sooner you forget about it that they
didn't advance your screenplay the
better off you are you're only looking
for at least three out of ten which
means seven out of ten are going to
close a door and as soon as you find out
they close your door just forget about
it it doesn't matter and certainly when
you get a door closed on your face and
your feelings are hurt don't tell the
people about it like you were a child
and you were petulant um because this is
a small town
everybody knows everybody and um i mean
you know nobody's really going to care
and i don't even know what the guy's
name was and i don't care but like
on the scale of like emotional maturity
um
you know emailing a festival that you
didn't get into whatever and telling
them to f off that's
pretty much the worst response you could
you could have to um show that you have
the emotional maturity to to do well in
this business
do you think rejection is like a muscle
and that it's just you learn that
eventually like it's it just doesn't
it doesn't it hurt as much if somebody
punches somebody's arm it it's almost
like
just the weaker arms get it
but then after a while you build it up
yes and i would even say the word
rejection is loaded with something bad
the better way to think about it is um
it's just part of the process you're
either winning this way or you're
winning that way oh i thought my script
was really good but i submitted it to
the blacklist and i only got a two oh
that's interesting what was it that
those professional readers saw
differently than what i thought because
i thought it was amazing
and then you go in and you figure out
how to close the gap so where's the loss
there's no loss there's no rejection
it's all part of the process
do you believe every screenplay a
screenwriter writes
begins with their five favorite movies
um
no
and
they're probably better off
leaning into their favorite films to
inspire
what's next for them
um because our favorite scripts our
favorite films or shows depending what
we're what we're
writing um
spoke to us in a deep way
um because let's i mean let's look at
this uh there's
tens of thousands of movies and shows
that we could have watched in our
lifetime lifetime you know one percent
of them or whatever we've actually seen
so thousands of people thousands of
movies and shows thousands of hours for
sure
if you get to the point where you're
writing a screenplay you've probably
seen
you know thousands of hours of content
so
of that let's say it's a thousand just
for hypothetical
which are the favorites
and why are those the favorites and then
when you get down to the specificity of
my favorite seven films it's not going
to be like anybody else's favorite seven
on the planet so you're talking about a
very specific almost code of what speaks
to me and if you take a look at that
there's connective tissue
in terms of theme or character arc or
genre
um
or just feel or tone or things and it
it's um
i found very instructive for me and for
writers that i mentor to
use that as the well i mean this is what
they could have picked anything right
they could have you know but the ones
that they saw and of the ones they saw
these are the ones that
sort of stirred their soul
so why would you not use that as a
resource to say
this is what i love most and now i'm
going to do my version of that
sure what if we're at a risk of putting
too many let's say we're taking from
black swan or
we're taking that you know from the
opening of forrest gump or what you know
we're infusing too many things that have
already been done and people can spot
that and say
yeah you were that that's derivative
right we recognize that so the um
what we're always looking for is the
same but different
if for um
if it's too much the same what you're
talking about then it feels too
derivative it's boring right if it's too
different
um
it's just it's too kind of weird it's
too idiosyncratic and it's like whatever
right
um
the stuff that's speaking to you
most deeply
has a beautiful balance of the same but
different someplace right in the middle
and when i create
my new version of the same but different
um
that's where the magic is i mean that's
really really profound beauty is um
if i
try to do that
and it's feeling derivative then i've
just leaned over to this poll too much
and i need to go okay i'm borrowing too
much from my favorite stuff how do i
make it more
personal to me
what was going on in my life
that inspired me to like that movie what
is it that
you know so if you look at something
like star wars right none of us were
star fighters or or uh you know what do
you call him um he's a
fighter pilot or whatever it was um
for the rebellion
but like
the way like in episode four i'm talking
about the way that he
um interacted with his his families and
uncle and the way he kind of was like
you know had to do his chores
and then um he had this calling to go on
this adventure to face the uh the empire
we relate to that because
if we do if we relate to that we're
living because we feel similar things in
our own sort of experience right so um
so if
episode four is on my list of favorite
movies um you know you might take that
it's sci-fi from it you might take that
it's a hero's journey story you might
take that it's um that he kind of had
this mundane sort of teenager type life
and he was called for some more sort of
adventure there's different things that
you can take and if i take x from it and
i'm putting at my screenplay and i'm
getting a reaction from people i respect
who are going yeah this feels like it's
too close to star wars then it's like
okay that's interesting how do i make it
more personal to me
you know because what i'm probably not
doing is going deep enough into what i
love about this that material
can i give this a try with some of my
favorite movies one of them being
forrest gump i might just be forrest
gump
um i mean i saw it when it came out but
it's such a iconic film so i have some
thoughts on it um
if that were on um
uh
somebody's list of favorite movies you
know you might take away again
the thing is to look at the whole series
right um if you look at seven and let's
say all of them are fairly similar to
forrest gump um
there's a there's a playfulness in that
there's an innocence it's sort of i mean
blake would call it the full triumphant
story um and so i would you know i would
look at that type of story i would look
at
the type of protagonist that was sort of
a special needs protagonist this idea
that life is nothing but a box of
chocolate so that's a thematic idea that
might speak to you
the setting it was like in the south
right in like georgia or some place or
alabama
so
i would take those elements and just
note them so that's a soft easy process
and then list your other six favorite
movies um and then you start looking
about like are there any other movies
that are full triumphant type movies
from blake snyder's professor or any
other movies that are sort of set in the
south or any other movies about um
characters that had special needs or any
other movies that have thematic idea of
sort of you know um
you know like like life is like a box of
chocolates or whatever that was or um
you know they talked about there was
sort of a nostalgia stuff going on in
there too so you just take the pieces
and you start looking through it so um
and then you will see connective tissues
and you'll realize
i'm drawn to these things for really
deep reasons and when you come with your
new material you create your new
material from those deeper reasons
it's almost certainly going to be
more resonant more singular and you are
speaking to that as a creative authority
on what you love the most because those
your favorite damn movies and you can
talk about them all day long as an
authority and so when you come from that
sort of
swagger and love and passion that's
exactly what hollywood is looking for
they're looking for you to be the
creative leader on your sensibility
because that's what we're doing when we
tell a story we're leading millions of
people on this journey from here to
there and we can't do it unless we're
comfortable and confident about what our
sensibility is so listing your favorites
and analyzing them as a way of sort of
making you already know what those are
but you're bringing it to a conscious
level to go yeah
i love these things and here's why i
love them and i can talk about them with
authority and from that authority
you put that on the page and then it
crackles in your own unique way and
speaks to other people
about uh russell crowe and i'm just
forgiving you the name it's where he's
the tobacco inside insider
yeah
fantastic yeah so if that was on the
same list as um
uh forrest gump so one connection i'm
seeing with that
movie is you have
you know also kind of the both of them
have like this innocent kind of
flustered um main character i mean
well yeah you know tom hanks character
isn't flustered but he runs and
crazy doesn't stop running but
the um the russell crowe character is
totally flustered and overwhelmed and so
to me those are very significant so if
those are two of your favorites i would
say there's something about being
sort of in over your head
less
you know sort of that fish out of water
thing but like
um but just sort of innocently kind of
stumbling into something and like being
like a really big deal um so those to me
are pretty significant and um
with insider there's also i mean that's
politically charged um it's socially
social issue charged um that one is
grounded to michael mann um perhaps at
his best one of my favorites from him
and you got pacino who's um
this you know dynamic um sort of
crusader
uh and you have that beautiful scene in
the courtroom of um
so good that well that one actor i don't
know his name but he's in that courtroom
scene and he just he sticks to the
tobacco company he was just basically
like look you knew this was wrong you
did it anyway it's now gonna stop you
can't push you can't bully us anymore so
it's that that bullying thing so maybe
that's the theme in you so again those
are just two movies if you brought out
the other five you can start seeing some
really significant
connective tissue
and then if you
you can almost see it like a lego set
right you're the lego set of your
favorite movies and then you take that
same lego set and then you create your
own new movie with those same legos and
maybe you add a few new ones but like
you are much more likely to to write
something that is so
connected to like your soul for the
reason that you came to the planet that
the thing that
who else are we going to go to about
those movies but you because they're
your favorite movies you can teach
anybody something about those movies
because your favorite so that's sort of
the way
that i help people get aligned with
their superpower or where i do myself
for my own work if i get a little bit
kind of
confused about something or resistance
i'm like well
how are they doing at my favorite movies
and i got to look at that
and i learn and i go okay well they did
this and they did this and they did this
and i go well i'm doing this this and
this and then it's like okay well how do
i make those dots connect how do i
connect apples to apples with my
favorites
um
and and then once i do it for me
i give it to somebody else and i go are
they seeing it you know because if it's
just me if i'm a professional it can't
be just me it's got to be
eliciting the reaction the other people
too which is even more fun anyway
can you explain the three elements of
creating a horror movie yeah it's a
great question that comes from blake
snyder's idea about the monster in the
house because blake has this really
wonderful elegant way of thinking about
genre that's different than what most
people think about genre when most
people think about genre they think of
sci-fi or western or horror or this or
that or the other
and blake was like well it doesn't
really help you write a screenplay
what's a way of thinking about
genre a way of sort of unified elements
that's going to keep you focused on
what's map what matters for you to
create
a screenplay with core elements that has
like the tuning fork that sounds like
wonderful
expression of that genre
so um
one of my favorites
is that monster
in the house genre and and that requires
a monster of some sort right um but it
need not be like supernatural could even
be like a psychopath or or you know
something terrible
and then a house
that's um
that's confined the protagonist so that
it's um
so they can't get away right so that the
monster is chasing them because if uh
there's no house then there's no tension
right the stakes are there because they
can't get away from the monster because
they're stuck in the house together
and then the most fascinating part about
it is the sin that's the third part and
the why is sin
and it's because
monster monster in the house movies
are
a morality tale
of when we
when you do something bad bad things
happen
so uh you know the classic um you know
kids tight teenagers go into the woods
to have pre-marital sex well then the
bad thing's going to happen the slasher
is going to come out and kill them right
but without that sin they're just kind
of you know
a couple walking their dog by the woods
and they get killed
it doesn't quite
doesn't quite hit us in that same way
because we're all attracted to sin and
we all sin to some degree or another and
so
monster in the house stories play on
that
vice
choice and terrible response and that's
part of the titillation of great horror
and
what's also really wonderful about what
blake thought about in that theory is
that he then said if you look at a movie
like jaws
um where the monster is the shark and
the contained the house is the cont is
the island where you know the sort of
the
amity island which was sort of like the
hamptons but like you know this
contained place um and then the sin
was that um
they knew the threat was there
but they didn't shut down the town or
didn't keep people away from the beach
because it was a tourist town and they
needed the money or they wanted the
money the greed was the same so that
makes the that's such an interesting
story and compelling in a different way
than if it didn't have that element
but then blake really ingeniously said
a movie like fatal attraction
he would also put in that monster in the
house things what you know certainly
jaws is like a horror movie but how
would you fail attractions like this
kind of psychological thriller
but let's look at the three elements
you've got
the monster which is glenn close playing
the psychopathic woman who just
was obsessed
with this guy
you've got the house was literally the
end was the house but it was really kind
of the family unit
right and the sin was adultery
so you have that same
primal pattern of
you know wanting something that you
really shouldn't go after and you do it
anyway and it brings out the monster and
then all hell breaks loose
great example so that doesn't
necessarily have to be a horror film it
can be a thriller it could be a drama
um i mean did you see dark waters i
didn't see doctors oh okay all right
we'll go into that one yeah but it it
can it absolutely can transcend what
traditionally we think of as genres it
could be sci-fi western it could be
anything um the key is
to blake's mind which i thought was
really great was
that core pattern you're gonna chances
of
making a
writing a script that makes a deeper
impact on people
is is much more likely if you take those
three elements and you sort of build
your story around those elements
no matter what sort of external genre
you place on it
does every genre have a certain amount
of elements a writer must know yeah
yeah they do it's um
because what what we're doing is
we're taking the audience on a very
personal journey even if it's a comedy
or whatever it is
um
and
the genre
is the set of expectations that the
audience is has been promised
for them to plunk down their money to
see the story
so if i promise them a comedy and it's
not funny they're going to be pissed off
and rightly so
um
if it's a horror movie
it's got to be scary it's a thriller it
has to have tension
and
so
a lot of
beginning writers
don't realize that they're not seeing it
as a relationship with the audience with
these promises
and genres are all about promises and
expectations and sometimes
beginning writers will go oh i've got
this cool idea and it's kind of this
genre and it's kind of where that genre
and it's kind of like that and it's like
yeah that's really creative
and um
you are planning to
alienate your audience um and it almost
never works
um there's some genres that can kind of
um
play nice together
uh you know one that a lot of people try
to do but very very rarely get get right
is like horror comedy
um edgar wright i think does it
masterfully better than anybody that
i've seen
but it's really hard and it's really
hard because comedy is so particular and
so the comedy has to be great
and then the amount of fear and the
scares has to be great so you're talking
about two really high bars that are
particular that's why most don't work
well and i think that
getting back to the other point is that
just early screenwriters sometimes when
i when i work with screenwriters they um
it's one of the ways that
their creativity gets in the way that
they um
it's like they um
they're building a car and they put
triangle wheels on the car
and um
that car is not going to go it is going
to be super creative it's going to be
really cool and i honor them for coming
up with those ideas but um it's not
going to get them to where they want to
go so um there's ways where you just you
know don't you take the round wheel you
can make a big round wheel or small
round wheel but make it a round wheel um
and then the creativity on top of that
then you can go wild so there's
um
yeah that's a common problem that
earlier writers have they don't know
which boxes can be totally crazy and
need to be crazy and and different and
which boxes are really more like an
engineering problem they just don't mess
with that
and genre is absolutely one of those
ones where
you
generally don't mess with it you go you
give them what they want and give them a
spin on it but it's really what they
want um you know even tarantino who
has a deep understanding of movies and
genre you know one of his i think least
successful movies was um from dusk till
dawn that he made with
rodriguez and i think it was just
because it was
it was a horror crime film and it
started literally started out as i think
more of a crime film and then took this
crazy left turn into a vampire movie um
which
even just saying it sounds like one of
those hey wouldn't it be cool
and then it was like this and then these
vampires came out you know
and um
you know those guys were at a point in
their career where they were killing it
and um they're like yeah this is really
cool and they loved it and you know and
people
you know uh i don't know if it was
profitable probably it might have been
profitable or not i don't think it was
or maybe over time it became profitable
but like ultimately i think it's a
really good case study of
an interesting idea
um but a fairly low ceiling in terms of
how many people are really going to love
it and i'm sure some people are like i
love that movie it's my favorite okay
great
and if your objective is to
deliver your voice
and service to your audience as
powerfully as possible for as broad of
an audience as possible
stick to one genre
and nail that genre and go take that
genre to the new place give it a fresh
spin on where it's going next
the audience
gaining trust the screenwriter
gaining trust of their audience is is it
different than this genre promise
no it's the same the one way to
establish trust with the audience is
if
i
you know
i've shown them a log line and it's this
particular genre and on page one they're
seeing
that it already feels like this genre on
page one
now i'm establishing more trust and if
i'm paid if i'm if it's a comedy and
there's nothing funny on page one
problems
and what about this i hate to call it
self-delusion but i'll just use that for
lack of a better term of a writer
thinking they're taking genre to new
heights but they're not really doing
that they're mixing it they're they're
playing with it in ways that really
aren't taking it to new heights so i
love that question because
um
it to me it feels like their intention
is dead on
and the execution is a mess
so um
if they have a high quality feedback
loop system
um it will tell them you know it'll be
like look i wanna i think i'm gonna have
some action and i'm gonna have some
comedy and i'm gonna do this i'm gonna
have that and um
the response to that sort of thing is
like look this is
it's kind of like a little bit of a lot
of things and i'd rather have a lot of
one thing um if they're getting high
quality feedback um and then that person
can go huh because i thought it was kind
of cool okay well i'm gonna make it
anyway if i'm an independent filmmaker
and then it'll play regional festivals
or whatever
or not at all
but like
if you want to blow people away
then you do sort of less from a deeper
place
and you fulfill that promise of genre of
these other things in a way that's
profound
and feels fresh and new so it's the same
but different it's familiar but fresh
um and uh
yeah genre is is one of the best ways to
do it and so the person that's kind of
like
in that scattered place where they've
got all these mishmashes um again it's
fine you know but they just have to just
compare the apples to apples i'm trying
to you know here's a comparable again
they're if they compare one apple that
they're trying to do with four different
apples that's the problem right no give
timmy one
movie that had this particular genre
that you love that was successful that
you you'd love to have that sort of
success with your screenplay what's that
apple how you create your apple and then
you figure out how you sort of can make
them the same so quentin tarantino tells
this great story
about when he was acting in the 80s
and uh he had this acting and at that
point in 80s you know you couldn't get
there was no internet so he couldn't get
scripts online he had to kind of like
watch the movies and you know take notes
and so he's in his acting class and he
um you know wrote down the scene from
this movie and handed it to his acting
partner and goes like you know we're
going to act in this
in the scene together and um
and the scene the right scene partner
goes well holy this monologue isn't
in the movie and quentin's like what oh
geez i'm sorry he goes no no this is
better than what's in the movie
and so um the takeaway there for the for
the amateur writer is um
what he did inadvertently was
realize that he as a writer was nailing
at a really high level
so um
amateur writers can use or any writer
can i use it all the time to sort of
compare apples to apples with any sort
of element if i'm trying to get better
at let's say tension or you know
certain dialogue or genre whatever i
look at what i think is the standard for
what i'm trying to do in another
thing and then i do my version of it and
i try to get the apple to the apple to
be the same in my view and then i get
feedback and are they looking at it and
going yeah brooks i can't tell which one
was written by you and which one was
written by you know legend a or whatever
now now i'm good
it's like fan fiction almost was doing
an early version of it
yeah yeah that's right that's right it
was a good look at it that's exactly it
and if you can do fan fiction that's as
good um you know i mean
yeah i mean there's you can you can get
work that way if you can play in that
universe in a way that's as powerful as
the you know the people already there
sure
so if i'm writing let's say a thriller
and i think oh wow i'm gonna really this
is this the thriller genre but i'm gonna
take it to new heights
and let's suppose it's like a wall
street corruption story and somebody
is the cleaning lady and she ends up
seeing people shredding documents but
then the people that are really the bad
guys turn out to be like reptilian
society people and that's i'm almost
that's not really taking it to a new
height that's
mixing genres because now i've got some
sci-fi in there and
they don't need to be reptiles you see
what i'm saying so i'm mixing but i my
assumption is i think oh i'm going to
take this to new heights but if i don't
get that feedback from the feedback loop
then i'm going to be
delusional and thinking that this is
just like never been seen before so
so
what i'll say about that is yeah i think
that the word delusional is sort of a
charged word that feels a little
distracting because
in this hypothetical where somebody's
like i'm trying to take the genre to a
new place perfect that's exactly what
we're doing that's exactly what
everything is that we love has done it
takes something not everything but a lot
of things that really break ground it's
because they're doing that so that
intention is dead on
and the truth is it takes trial and
error to be able to get that it's like i
want to make the best new heist film
ever right awesome um
that's what i'm trying to do
where am i at now so to say where i'm at
how is delusional i was like okay fine
but like i mean it's kind of a negative
way of saying it's just like you you are
where you are and then and then you just
kind of figure out here's what i'm
trying to get to here's where i am now
how do i sort of get there and um and
being gentle with ourselves and
thinking of ourselves or other people is
like delusional is kind of a it's a
distracting way of of the matter-of-fact
business of getting the apple to match
the apple and if um
and the impulse to go
the way that i'm going to take it to
that next level is adding a bit of this
genre that genre
um
maybe it's just you know it's it's sort
of like um
you know just you know get a feel for
these things you know i mean it's like
sometimes some genres do have aspects
that do play nice together you know or
harmonize really nice together um and
some things kind of clash you know
they're sort of um
you know somebody can you know do a
website design or just a set of colors
and some people have a knack for like
those colors look nice again or like the
way you dress you know
some people can do it some people can't
people like it and we don't but like
it's that set of artistic choices that
harmonize together or not and so um
so
uh it's a matter of playing with which
story elements end up harmonizing in the
right way to get to the point where
you're taking the genre the next level
so i would never describe it as
delusional when they're in the process
of doing the damn thing that they should
be doing
brooks we're going to give you
14 idea fragments you don't have to use
everything you don't have to use all of
them you can throw any of them away
except one and we want to see how far
you can get into the process while
taking us through
your process the best you can and for
those of you watching if you want to
play along at home great please do the
same and we welcome you to pause the
video and see what you can come up with
and compare your ideas to a professional
writer okay are we ready i'm ready okay
screenwriters on your marks so here we
go 14 idea fragments
single mom single mom
500 000
500k
a train a train
memory loss that we lost
what i forget that's right
logic
a small town in michigan small town
michigan okay the power of silence
power of silence
a yellow bag
yellow bag
a man with a checkered coat
man
with a
checkered
coat two friends who haven't seen each
other in 20 years
two
friends
who haven't
seen
each other
20 years
an abandoned castle
and
uh abandoned castle butchered that
spelling of abandon that's fine
okay
a life-threatening dare
a
life
threatening
dare
a mismatched pair of detectives a
mismatched
pair of detectives
rebirth rebirth
and lastly this piece of dialogue
okay they don't realize how powerful i
am
they don't realize
how
powerful i am
cool
okay great so the first thing
i'm thinking about is
what spoke to me like when i go down
these prompts it's like what is it
um
where where do i feel like i might have
a personal
take on something right single mom um
my mom was single so that i feel
something 500k is a significant amount
of money um
maybe i mean it's sort of
you know heists and crass and it's sort
of material and maybe trane is a great
location certainly a big history in um
cinema history of trains or strangers on
a train or
lots of different i actually wrote up
the first screenplay that i wrote was a
passenger that i that i sold was
commuters on the l train in chicago
getting
trapped in the blizzard
during an alien invasion
so um
but i can't do that i already wrote that
one so um that's that memory loss
is certainly interesting um but not so
much to me i'm gonna put that one aside
um small town michigan okay maybe
um certainly i spent some time in the
midwest so that's possible but probably
more toward the end of the list
doesn't i'm more called to the train and
then you later have a location with the
um
the castle an abandoned castle which is
kind of interesting um
i
visited england once and um
went to see a castle and it was
it's interesting it's what's nice about
that it's an elevated location it's sort
of just it could be a warehouse right
but it's
you know has this history and um
and it has all these metaphorical
powers to it so maybe there's something
there um
power of silence that's interesting um
one of the things that makes cinema
powerful is um you can just watch what
people are doing
and you can um
it can it can hit you on a deep level uh
scorsese said uh once someplace that i
really appreciated he
he would sometimes watch his own films
if they came on tv or whatever and he
turned the sound off and just kind of
watches
his shot selection which is a really
good way to focus on your subtext what
are the characters doing what do they
want
also it's a great way to make sure the
scene construction is is muscular and
powerful
if you had the sound off
um could you see what the conflict was
and what are they doing so um
yeah so there's something there
certainly lends itself well a yellow bag
i mean that was going to be used to pull
over somebody's head to kill them
okay otherwise
i'll feel connected to that man with a
checker coat
that sounds like something
potentially could be in some sort of
detective piece or whatever i'm not that
called
about that two friends who haven't seen
each other in 20 years um i am all over
that um i had deep
relationships with people i went to high
school with
um
and childhood too and that's probably
pretty common but there was the the i uh
in nyu my senior thesis film was about
me
uh was based on when i took my
girlfriend home to my hometown and i had
really close relationships with my guy
friends and i kind of
got myself in a situation to be choosing
between my girlfriend and my guy friend
ended up winning a screenwriting award
there um
so that's um
to me that's the most loaded and
interesting
idea of everything so far right and who
knows maybe this is two single moms who
haven't seen each other in a long time
and maybe they're on a train and maybe
they're gonna rob the train for five or
thousand dollars you had a terrible idea
but anyway that's just um that's not
where i'm going but um single moms
haven't seen each other in 20 years i
mean i'm not a single mom so i wouldn't
go too far into that as my protagonist
probably um
i can i write women
they're half the people on half the
characters in all my screenplays so i
can um
like these days
me being a white straight male
um writing a single mom driven movie is
you know there's resistance there um and
it's it's other people's story so um
uh the son of a single mom my bad that i
get that's personal to me um
but these two friends haven't seen each
other 20 years they meet on a train
is definitely something that is speaking
to me see single mom maybe
um
maybe one of them is traveling with
their single mom that feels personal to
me um and maybe they're going to see
this abandoned castle in london right or
outside of london so now what i'm doing
is i'm taking these elements and i'm
connecting to
things that have happened in my life
that i could
bring out authenticity with i could make
them something that it's like what's my
personal way in when i write with this
one writing partner
um
you know his superpower is sort of
creativity and inventiveness and he
loves sci-fi and fantasy my superpower
is grounded characters person grounded
personal characters and i write tension
that's really thick
generally in dramas or thrillers so when
i write with him it's like where's the
double filter where do we both
um like when we both speak to so um
uh and so sometimes when we're looking
at fragments it's sort of
you know when he and i are maybe
brainstorming new concepts or when i
brainstorm myself i kind of take
fragment ideas and i kind of start and
if he and i guess the reason i brought
up is he and i are disagreeing about
something he like kind of likes
something i go yeah but i don't have any
personal connection to it
and then we go okay fine i'm going to
the next one or vice versa so that's
what i'm looking for here when i'm
seeing these fragment ideas it's like
what's my what's my personal connection
to it
if i'm in a general meeting with a
producer or something like i got this
book and we're thinking about bringing
in a writer to adapt it or whatever um
i go great let me hear it and
i'm looking for some sort of connection
because um
i can make it sing when i'm writing
about this dude i went to high school
with who fascinates me you know that
that's really what i'm writing about and
i'm just sort of doing it in this
certain way that kind of connects so um
okay a life-threatening dare
probably not a dare doesn't interest me
um
i'm putting that at the bottom of the
list
next in yellow bag which i won't use a
mismatched pair of detectives well
that's sort of if i was
working with like a producer who was
like i want to do a movie and it's got
to have a mismatch
[Music]
all right i might you know it's part of
the you know
like maybe these two friends they meet
on the train they haven't seen her in 20
years and something terrible happens on
the train maybe it stops in the middle
of the woods or something and um they
have to be a mismatched pair of
detectives to figure out what the hell
happened um you know i'm just kind of
i'm
there's two things i'm doing i'm trying
to say what what is it that i can bring
something to from my perspective on life
um and then how do these elements sort
of piece that together but the key is
not to force it right a mismatched pair
you know
that element in general mismatch para
detective feels a little
you know a little forced to me um but it
can be really fascinating because
detectives are interesting if you're
doing any sort of mystery story and
mismatch is always good because
you know we all have poles inside of us
part of us that's this and part of us
that's that and
you know any sort of buddy love story
what blake snyder would call has
these two different characters learning
from each other so maybe you know these
detectives are
[Music]
pieces that need to learn how to fit
together so that's possible um
that's possible rebirth i mean that's
kind of a theme
[Music]
sure
you know we all have rebirths
times but i wouldn't really
force a theme that much at this point i
don't think man with the sugar coat
we're back to and then
they don't realize how powerful i am
um i mean
there's definitely some juice there you
could do something with that line in a
certain way um
um it's kind of a heartbreaking way to
take it if you um
if the character really doesn't believe
it
um the character is in this place of
going i'm not enough i'm not good enough
whatever
and says
they don't realize how powerful i am but
doesn't mean it at all
you know um the subtext of that is
really beautiful and heartbreaking and
that would maybe um yeah anyway so um
so yeah i mean that's so you know that's
that's a little bit uh 10 minutes so
this is how i would approach it so i'm
kind of i basically um reorganize the
list and put the ones that were like the
ones that i had some sort of connection
to more towards the top and towards the
bottom and for the hypothetical if i was
going to go for further i would just
you know at first you know i mean that's
not how it works i mean
working the businesses they'll say i've
got this story and maybe it has some of
these elements
i mean it might
there might be some sort of novel that
has those sort of elements but this is
sort of missing
the narrative drive or something so um
which tends to be more the core part of
a story which is why somebody would
option a book
or something um but like um
does that answer your question in terms
of how i would think about these things
in terms of putting them into a story
like if you were to take some of these
pieces
whether you used just one what if you
just all you did was was build it around
the two friends who hadn't seen each
other in 20 years okay you just said
okay i'm going to take that and you know
that that resonates with you because you
have close relationships with people
from your hometown yeah and so
okay you can go somewhere else so you
want me to come up with a concept based
on um one of these pieces sure and if
one if one and if you say you know what
actually this yellow bag what if one of
them finds 500 000 in a yellow bag and
now they have a moral dilemma do i turn
it in what do i do yeah yeah interesting
um well i'll pitch an idea that um these
two friends are on the train and they
haven't seen each other in um
20 years
and um
maybe they had a history of some
some bad things back in high school they
did maybe not too bad but like some
trouble um and one guy's desperate and
he's gotten
an opportunity to steal 500 thousand
dollars from x right so um
and he hasn't seen this guy in 20 years
and he knows at least back the way he
was before that like this guy is is the
perfect guy it's almost like strangers
in a train which is the premise there or
the hitchcock story was um i'll do your
murder you do my murder and that way we
have no alibi and we're both
um
we're both more likely to get away with
it so maybe i would pitch this as a spin
on that but it's not um
hitchcock was great but he also had a
very kind of
you know bulk boxy sort of stiff you
know performances and kind of you know
it was just older different different
time um
but if it was like a um
yeah a modern story two friends that
haven't seen each other and this one
guys already has this heist in mind
um
and desperately needs his 500
and runs into this friend and is like oh
my god this guy's the perfect guy to do
it and then what's
what's the blocking agent why is um
is it the guy you know um
like maybe even like
one guy's a dirty cop right so one guy's
a dirty cop and and the guy that sees
him is now a criminal and maybe he's
trying to recruit one guy's trying to
recruit the other for some sort of heist
or something
these guys are best friends in high
school
and um so what i'm doing is i'm sort of
pitting
sort of deeper personal elements in a
way that
could feel kind of personal not that
i've ever robbed anything or anything
like that but like um loyalties among
friends
and taking some sort of risk for a heist
experience is pretty
compelling i like high stories i like i
like crime stories so um
yeah so i could see that as sort of a i
mean it's kind of a low
low
you know there's high concept there's
low concept um
but you know it's it's okay it's it's
interesting so if you were to so if
let's say that's the story so let's say
um
i'll write a log line out of it when
two friends two
they were not what kind of friends they
were um outsiders they were um two kind
of
down and out friends one's a cop we were
called down and out
friends
um
one cop
and
one
crook
who haven't seen each other in 20 years
um
meet
on a train
um
they
decide to
team up
to
steal 500 000 right so that's functional
um
but like
so that's like
and that's actually where a lot of sort
of beginning writers might stop right
okay they do it and then the but the
problem is if you don't go any further
with that concept
it's just flat it's sort of like i mean
you have to
that dialogue would have to be
phenomenal and crackling and amazing
so what really makes this better as a
concept is
who are these friends is is one's a cop
what kind of cop is he how how dirty is
he and then um and if it's like this
thing where the the crook needs to
the cop for one thing and the cop needs
a crook for one thing and then there's
these loyalties that are at play and who
knows maybe um
you know maybe they stopped being
friends because one guy hooked up with
his girlfriend back in high school
um
and then that comes up at a climatic
part where one guy never really effing
free freedom for it
um
you know um
you know i could write a story like that
i mean again it doesn't feel i mean i'm
looking at it for 17 minutes now but
like um
uh
but this is the process i would go into
it and i would say what and and i and if
i was i first of all i wouldn't put a
ticking ticking clock and i would kind
of play with it for a little bit and
then i would sit down and set it down
i'd go someplace else and then was in
the shower or whatever might come to me
and go okay what if what if this
happened with this guy and then what if
that happened and i would play with it
and then i would get it to a point where
um you know i felt like okay this is
something that's kind of interesting and
then i would pass it around to my
feedback circle say what do you guys
think is this um
you know i might have them rate it from
one to ten
um i might just pitch it to them and
then look at the response and if
um again i you know
step one would be me getting to a place
like
that i feel like i'm really excited to
me right now what i put together is
rudimentary it's like level six out of
ten as a sort of concepts right um it's
much easier if you start a new script
and it's like a level nine concept or
level 10 concept right which is unlikely
for you know most people to do when
they're sitting it's looking at
something for 15 minutes but that's the
things we you know we don't have to do
this we have as much time as we want so
um i would just keep going back to the
well and playing with it what about this
or what about that and then you know if
i ever felt a little forced and just put
it away and then just do something else
and then once i got it up to a point
where i felt like oh this is actually
really great and also the other thing
that i'd be looking for
that's really good that i got from blake
snyder is irony so where could you add
some irony to the story so two down and
out friends one's a cop one's a crook
they haven't seen each other in 20 years
they meet on a train
one guy realizes that he's super
desperate and he's got a shot at
stealing 500 000 bucks
and his friend from high school was the
perfect accomplice
but
yeah they you know one guy slept with
this
they stopped talking 20 years ago
because one guy slept with his
girlfriend and um they got to deal with
that or maybe that's got to be dealt
with upfront and then he goes okay we'll
do it and that breaks into sec into your
second act um
and then
as we go deeper
you know why did he sleep with the
girlfriend
what did they really love about each
other um that was betrayed back then you
know what do they really need as people
um and then the movie really becomes
about
uh you know i don't know if it comes
about a rebirth but it comes about them
sort of
because i had deep friendships in high
school i mean these guys i love these
guys because partly because my father
wasn't around as much as i want him to
be so i have abandonment stuff so
one way that i dealt with that
abandonment stuff was having really
tight friendships so um
uh
my friends and i did not sleep with each
other's girlfriends
but um you know there's betrayals of
different sorts or whatever but i would
sort of tap into that thing and
it would probably have to do with some
if i was going to write this or develop
it and i had to use those elements i
would start playing around this idea of
abandonment and how i dealt with
abandonment and how these guys have
dealt with abandonment and what they do
about it and
um
yeah so that's kind of
that's
that's what i got i mean that's sort of
my process in you know looking at it for
20 minutes um
you know how i would approach it why
would i i would approach it that way um
and at the level that i got to this what
i will say is
a this is like i said
i don't know 60 70 it feels like it's
it's there if it's what would make this
from just being an exercise to something
like oh this is amazing i want to really
write this at some point
probably another element or two maybe
there's a sense of irony that i could
bring into it or maybe a way to elevate
it maybe it doesn't take place sort of
modern day but maybe it takes place on
the moon or the international space
station or something or takes place in
like the 1860s and i'm in a place where
i really want to
you know explore that sort of thing
but what i'm looking for is that
personal connection to it something that
i feel like
yeah i'm on the planet to do this you
know and then another thing i would do
early on is going okay well what is it
like okay it's sort of like strangers on
the train but like you know i admire
stuff about that but that doesn't really
speak to me um now pat garrett and billy
the kid
the peck and paw film from 72 or 73
that blows me away and that's about
friendship and betrayal so maybe i do
that maybe i go in and go okay
two friends who haven't seen each other
and maybe it's sort of like with
pacquiao and billy the kid they were
outlaws together and then they were
pitted against each other um so maybe i
would do that i would kind of milk what
i love from that comparable and i would
go okay
how would peck and paul do this how
would this happen um
so um and again the key is not forcing
it so i would never put a 20 20 minute
um
or whatever never put a time limit i
would i would just get in there and play
around and that get to the point where
if it was fun to keep playing i would
and if it stopped being fun i'd just do
something else
maybe with a different story maybe
whatever um and if i was
in a meeting with a producer and they
were pitching this idea it would still
be the same thing it's like you know i
either can bring uh
something
to what this you know the guy's vision
is for what he wants to do whether it's
an original or an adaptation or
something um or i can't
and i'm not attached to either outcome
you know because it's that's the thing
it's because it's
it exists beyond me it's like i'm not
even it's not me the more i think it's
like me my screenplay blah blah blah
it's like that just gets in the way what
i'm doing is trying to be in service
to the audience that would want to see
this let's say it's a crime thriller or
a heist film and um and if i am the man
to
serve them with these sort of ideas that
just came to me and they're in service
great you know and you want to pay me a
lot of money for that awesome and um
and i'm not i'm not attached to anything
but you were able to find things that
you emotionally plugged into even if it
was just 60 70 percent there like the
man with the checkered coat you were
like yeah yeah whatever abandoned castle
yeah i've been to one it was kind of
cool it was eerie but it wasn't
something that
you really felt like maybe a deep
connection with but the two friends that
hadn't seen each other
that really
and why is because my personal
life
my psychology my psyche was formed
around this abandonment issue my dad
took you know my parents split when i
was in third grade my dad died when i
was 17. so i dealt with abandonment as a
core
issue
um my whole life and so i have
world-class insights about how to deal
with abandonment in good ways and in bad
ways and everything in between so um
you know you've got abandonment issues
you come to me and i'll you know we'll
have a conversation and my stories um
when they come from that place now
you know what i mean now it's like it
makes some sense right um
and i can touch on other things but like
that's that was a core one for me so
that's why those friendships meant so
much to me um and i mean it was like and
i would not only i had a
group of friends in high school but i
had like best friends and we were like
this you know really
you know a couple different ones but
like
and it was probably because i was
hurting so much because i missed my
father um
so um that
for a screenwriter to have that sort of
insight into whatever however your
psychology works and however your
triggers work
can
then fuel the choices that you make so
they're loaded up so that you're not
just writing oh
i'm doing an action film it's like yeah
that's that but it's actually a metaphor
for this time in my life where it drove
me crazy and broke my heart and
um
because
the movies that we love and shows that
we love are melting our hearts because
um
the people creating them are basically
sharing their memoirs with us
they're sharing their diaries and most
intimate vulnerable places in their life
with
archetypes or personified in these
characters that are iconic in a way so
that i look at good fellas and i feel
like that's my me and my friends and we
never did anything with a mob i grew up
on
new york but like
way different side of long island and um
and there was blue color there were
similarities but again like nothing like
those guys and yet exactly like those
guys
and that's because scorsese and pelegi
were so specific with the people that
they grew up with and they allowed that
to manifest in a movie like goodfellas
and with such delight and specificity
that um
yeah it feels like
it's my story
you say andy dufresne is not the
protagonist in the shawshank redemption
that's correct uh
technically
the helpful way to think about the
protagonist is the one
who changes the most and has the most
agency and impact
on the change so um
in that story
andy for sure
drives the narrative i mean he is a
freight train of hope
all the way through that movie um he
hopes right in the beginning he hopes in
the middle and he hopes at the end and
he has a little bit of a doubt here and
there but for the most part he's
non-stop hope he dug himself out of that
damn prison with like a spoon or
something you know ridiculous or i guess
a rock hammer um
red the morgan freeman character
is um i mean it's not just that he's
narrating but it's also significant that
he's narrating because he starts in
despair
and he says and they get to the middle
and he's kind of picking up that this
guy andy and they've already been there
15 years at that point picking up he's
this guy andy's all about hope and he
goes hope
you can't hope in here it'll get you
killed in here right um
and that's that part of us that
considers hope versus despair
um and
that movie represents um
red in that movie is the protagonist and
he represents
how part of us can
realize that um
when we choose hope in no matter what
situation especially when it's really
bleak like it is in that film
um
we actually liberate ourselves and we
free ourselves to the point where
there's a character named brooks and i
really like that name brooks
where he gets out
and um the old guy is so
you know
accustomed to that the other people and
is so he kind of is sort of a
happy-go-lucky character but like
he doesn't have enough hope and optimism
to be able to sort of rebuild his life
and so he turns right back to despair
and ends up killing himself really
beautiful
turn and counterpoint this idea of hope
versus despair but no for sure
i would analyze that movie with um
uh morgan freeman's character red being
the protagonist um and one more thing
about that story um is that
when they um
i believe the way the book uh ends which
is really wonderful it ends with
um morgan freeman or not more friendly
the red character in the book just
saying i hope i hope he's basically
learned to hope
and you don't know if he ever sees andy
and to me
that is sort of a deeper more resonant
lesson that
like it's easy to hope if you know
you're going to get it
the rub is can you hope can you believe
can you be open when you haven't gotten
it yet and you don't know if you're ever
going to get it and when red learns to
do that even though he hasn't gotten a
reconnection with andy
to me that really hits hard so i believe
they did that in the actual movie
version and um
people were pissed off they didn't like
it
so they think they did they re-shot the
ending where they actually reunite and
people loved it so you know um
we're in service to the audience and i
think the audience loved
seeing hope be overtly rewarded to them
it landed more deeply
so when stephen king wrote the book it
was a novella
okay it's part of a wonderful novella
called uh different seasons uh stand by
me that movie was it was a movie it was
a great story called the body that's
kind of like the the rob reiner film but
a little darker and more interesting um
and uh so that and then apt pupil is
another one there's like four stories
and i think three out of the four were
made into um movies wow
and i understand that
you said something about and you did a
video on your youtube channel about uh
how the law of attraction powers the
shawshank redemption and um we can put a
link to it below here um our video
but you feel that the maybe the title of
the movie hurt its success in the
initial release yeah yeah for sure
in my opinion and one of my writing
partners is one of the top marketing
minds in hollywood um
so doesn't mean that i'm always wrong or
he's over a bit like he's he's good so i
have a pretty good feel for
marketing stuff and
my opinion is that when you have um an
unusual title like what the hell does
that even mean shawshank redemption
everybody knows what redemption means
but nobody knows what shawshank means so
um
the job of marketing is you're beginning
to tell the story you never want to
confuse people you can intrigue them and
i think that's why they justify a title
like that is that it's intriguing in a
way
and in this case it was built on ip that
maybe people were familiar with and so
they were kind of you know letting it go
but like
the marketing campaign and the title you
choose is the beginning of telling the
story and
the better way to tell the story is
clear this is what my story is it's a
story about this or that you know um so
that's ideal um
but you know sometimes
you know the coen brothers always have
kind of funky sounding titles but like
you know the cone brothers movies get
sold because of mostly them and their
brand and their sort of style their
super power so um
you know there's certainly exceptions to
the rule but i think if you take
shawshank redemption and you give it a
different title it makes a much bigger
splash earlier on i mean it made a big
splash later because of the reaction but
i think it um there were much better
titles than that
and i think the book was the book like
ava gardner or something really really
read okay
we're sorry the other other actress okay
yeah and then the shawshank or something
rita hayworth and the shawshank
redemption
which is fine for a novella you know i
guess i don't know anything about book
marketing um maybe no difference at all
there but in movie marketing there's so
much noise
you absolutely will get a bigger
audience when you have a great title and
it
cuts right through the noise in a way
that totally beautifully positions
the audience for the rest of the story
and it's the beginning of the story that
you tell so like a knife you want a
cutting through the noise
when you broke down the shawshank
redemption in your video you talked
about letting go of outcomes
and not being attached
if we think of a writer how should they
let go of outcomes or maybe they
shouldn't maybe that's something that's
not that they shouldn't never be too
free-flowing with letting something go
well
um
they should always let go should they be
completely free-flowing
pretty much um
but not so like loosey-goosey where you
just kind of wandering around aimlessly
right there's
what we want for sort of
to cross our next career milestone as
quickly as possible
we want to have a clear sense of where
we're going
and conviction towards it
and
a joy and an ease and a lack of
attachment and we don't
ultimately
it's about that
process of getting there the um it's
like the way i talk about sometimes is
that it's a um it's a treadmill
you know um you're you're jogging on the
treadmill and it's a beautiful treadmill
and once you get to one milestone guess
what there's just another milestone and
then once you get to that second
milestone guess what there's another
milestone right so you're already on the
damn treadmill so this idea of i'm gonna
break in well you write a screenplay
today you've already broken in
essentially are you getting paid for it
yet no
but the paradox is
the less attached to it and the more
you're there just to serve your audience
as powerfully as you can
the quicker you'll cross the milestones
that get you to the point where they're
paying you lots of money
you also broke down in your video
victim
energy when it comes to the law of
attraction
and attracting sort of victim
circumstances
versus empowerment energy that's right
how do screenwriters do that
oh wow
uh you ever heard of this thing called
twitter
um
uh actually you see both on twitter
really wonderful positive powerful
energy and lots and lots of um
victim choices i can't make it to
hollywood because of this excuse i'm to
this i'm to that i'm to the other
they don't get me
woe is me i have no power it's just it's
really a fascinating
choice
that um
a habit that people have of giving away
the power giving away the power giving
away the power when we have
the choice to do
the opposite i'll take the power i'll
take it off you know i'm responsible i
can choose yes hollywood has bias yes
some groups are more favored than other
groups yes yes yes it's all true and you
can succeed despite that how you go
apples to apples you're trying to do
this you're seeing what's already out
there with this you figure out a way to
close that gap you position yourself as
the best person to do the next
you know
thing in this genre the person who's
gonna
write horror in a new way or this in a
new way or that in a new way and if you
do that they don't care what you look
like where you came from at all
you need to deliver the goods and in
fact
if you are
related to a celebrity or studio head or
whatever
and that door is
wide open for you if you don't have the
goods you're not going to get work
either this idea that nepotism is what
fuels all these things it's bs i mean
it's a factor but it's this much of a
factor what's really a factor is
delivering the goods and if you got the
goods they don't care where you came
from they don't care who you are any
type if you've got the goods they'll be
happy to work with you and will try to
sell you and if you have all the
connections in the world
and you're not delivering the goods
guess where you go director jail writer
jail you get nothing and that's exactly
what happens there and these ideas of
that hollywood's is closed place is bs
because of director jail you know what i
mean it's like you got to put up what's
true is that you're only as good as your
last picture that sort of thing i mean
that's um that's a negative way to spin
it but that's the truth i mean it's like
um
the internet makes pretty much anybody
you want to get to accessible
you know one way or another and you're
not everybody but like most of the
people or if not not them directly
probably people they know and if you
impress them
but the truth of it is um
you know people
just aren't
developed enough in their craft to do
something that's impressive enough to
get to people who can get to people to
get it moving you know
and then uh and instead of just going
okay yeah i'm on the way i'm learning
whatever they go oh hollywood's closed
people
um you know they don't like my type
because of this or that and um
again there is bias i'm not saying there
isn't but it's a tiny part and when you
focus on the bias you are giving your
power away you are leaking it and you
are distracting yourself from your
greatness and you are
you're just out of alignment from your
deeper goal which is to be in service of
your audience which is all about coming
from your power and being there and
helping them
and in the shawshank redemption some of
the character arcs went from victim
[Music]
attraction attracting victim-like um
situations to reversals of that with
let's say the prison warden
so he was maybe more empowered at one
point and then because of some things
that he did then it took a reverse turn
whereas with red it was
so different character arcs happen i
mean how much should we be thinking
about things like that the law of
attraction in relation to our characters
what are they attracting well we
shouldn't think about the law of
attraction at all unless um
we like it unless it speaks to us unless
um we see real value in it there's
aspects of the way people talk about the
law of attraction that are really
sort of off-putting to a lot of people
and for good reason
um
and uh and if you're
you know and if your curiosity stops
there then you shouldn't be thinking
about it um
it's uh it's been significantly
beneficial for me and for other people
i've seen
um put it into practice things happen
and it feels good and it's fun and it's
easier and it works
that's my experience people should have
their own experience and see if it works
for them maybe it does maybe it doesn't
um
for shawshank redemption in terms of the
victim energy the first thing came to my
mind was that character that um
cracked that first night so um so
uh andy dufresne comes in and then that
heavier character
um
uh was um
he cracks he was he's the one that just
he gets so overwhelmed with his fear
that um
he ends up crying and i think that the
guard actually comes in and then beats
him down and he dies because of his
wounds so um
and that from a looked at from a law of
attraction perspective was like he
brought that on himself he was
so deeply in the habit of
giving away his power not being able to
feel the terror that he felt being in
this new place
that he
spiraled to a place where he made things
worse and he made things worse and he
made things worse
um to the point where he actually killed
him right
and we all do that sometimes and we all
have the power to do that a little bit
less and a little bit less and when we
do it a little bit less so often that we
actually almost never do it we just hold
our power and we come from our power
more often
your example about the warden is really
interesting so he starts out clearly
with lots of power
um and then comes to a point where but
he's he's completely corrupt
so he's doing it
he's not using his power in service of
his people
so um
why what's going on beneath that he's
ultimately he's got the material power
he's in charge but he's not
he's not in alignment he's actually
he's a victim
and he's he's a victim even though he's
technically in charge and he's coming
from that victim place
as a tyrannical leader
because the tyrannical leader is not in
service of his or her people
they are coming from their victim energy
so um
so when he falls at the end it is still
saying the same theme that it's always
better to find hope and and despair and
victim energy will always cycle you down
to terrible places even if you are and
that's actually that's the connection
between the two characters is that you
have the warden who started out very
powerful but basically
was in this energy of victim and lack
and i didn't believe in genuinely
serving people so he had to cheat and
steal and lie
and it basically drove him into a place
of despair
and that character that came in as the
the fresh fish
the uh the guy that cracked under the
pressure was the same thing but he
didn't he he just
his demise happened so quickly because
he came he started from a place of less
power but they both are thematically
proving
the the the thematic statement of that
piece that um
that when we hope we get good things
when we despair we get bad things or
from law of attraction language when we
are open to our power
um or we start with the negative part
when we are sort of
bringing in victim energy or lack energy
or that sort of thing it leads to
despair when we bring in our power
and our flow and our ease and our belief
and our hope and our patience it leads
to triumph
should so just the way people sort of
use the hero's journey yeah to as a
backdrop against their story
if someone is open to the law of
attraction and
whatever woo parts scare maybe some
people others are open to um what what
templates can they apply to their story
with the law of attraction
geez um
i don't know if i would
call it a template it's like um
my understanding the law of attraction
there's been you know people talking
about this probably for thousands of
years in one way or another but in the
20th century there was
some you know people writing about it
sort of the turn of century and then in
the last i know 20 or 30 years there's
been other people writing books about it
there's that movie the secret that that
was you know touching on it and um
but it's like uh
i don't know i mean it's yeah
it's more of a it's
the tool that
screenwriters can take from it is more
of a mindset approach it's like look the
doors are going to close in your career
for sure how do you want to respond to
that
in a way where you're like oh no the
door closed blah blah that's terrible oh
i didn't get into this
you know screenplay competition or oh
this person didn't buy my script or
whatever it is there's oh this person's
not returning my phone call
you have a choice in how you can respond
to that and um and when you choose to
respond to that from your inner
sovereign energy as a king or a queen
saying i reached out to another kingdom
and it didn't work out fine i'll reach
out to another kingdom and then i'll
reach out to another kingdom and then
i'll reach out because you know why
that's who i am i am a king and i reach
out to other kingdoms and i do business
when i find my kindred spirits and
that's just it because this is a
treadmill and i'm just in it to be here
and to do things and yes at some point
i'll find the right person and we can
marry our kingdoms together and do
something amazing and until that point
cares because i'm showing up as me and
i'm just doing it